This is Jocko podcast number 67 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
We are soldiers,
marines,
grunts,
ground pounders,
infantry men.
Okay.
Jarheads Tommy's doughboys Gis.
We march,
we walk for miles.
Miles that don't stop.
Miles that don't end miles that are filled with fear,
okay?
Fear of the unknown,
fear of the enemy,
fear of wounds,
fear of death.
But we march on
our boots,
tried a stomp that fear into the ground.
People talk of glory on the battlefield,
but it is only talk
on the battlefield.
There is only guttural instinct to survive and protect your brother.
Okay?
Things are done not for glory,
okay,
but for love,
we march on
we march in the heat and the cold and the rain and the snow.
Yeah,
we marched to deserts and streets and in the valleys and up the hills,
every step we take is a new step into the unknown.
But at the same time
it is a step that has been taken thousands of times before by other soldiers and
all their times.
The names change.
The weapons change.
The cause is different,
but the faces,
the faces are the same.
The man does not change.
The fear is the same as is the will,
the hardened will to drive on to move forward.
Tomorrow
we close with the enemy,
okay?
Be it swords or bayonets.
Rifles are machine guns,
spears,
or grenades,
daggers,
or our bare hands,
okay?
We bring our to bear
and on leash them with fury,
okay?
There is no crowd watching,
There are no admirers.
It is only us.
And when one of our brothers is killed,
it rips us apart.
Okay?
Magnificent men,
the best of us,
beautiful human beings filled with hopes and dreams and filled with life,
Indian death,
all those hopes and all those dreams and all of that,
life is drained away,
taken away,
thrown away.
And in that moment
when a warrior falls,
the whole world should come to a standstill.
The whole world should stand and bow their heads and grieve the loss of that
hero,
okay?
The whole world should stop and get on their knees and prays what that man has
sacrificed and acknowledge this supreme made on corrupted eminence
of that soldier.
Yeah.
Of that warrior,
okay?
But the world does not stop.
The world carries on.
It is only we warriors that truly more.
It is us alone that bow our heads.
It is us alone that bow our heads and horn,
the loss of that fallen saint.
Okay.
The saint who has given everything
for us.
Then
we warriors.
Yeah,
we raise our heads,
we raise our heads again in with fire in our hearts,
we lock and load our weapons and we march,
we march forward toward fear and toward evil and toward our fate.
We march forward without any question of what is at stake.
We march forward not for reward
but for duty,
not for ourselves
but for each other.
We march forward not for glory but for love
forward
forever.
We march on
good evening,
echo did evening.
I was asked the other day by a nother veteran how to cope with losing friends
and
I answered that question and in that answer
as I've thought about it afterwards,
no,
I,
I thought of this eternal warrior,
this warrior that's been around since man has existed,
hungry,
tired,
scared,
but heroic.
Heroic in his ability to put those discomforts aside in do,
but what he must do.
And tonight we're going to look
at another book about another band of brothers
going back once again to World War II,
back on the European continent,
a book by a guy by the name of Charles MacDonald,
who served as a company commander during the war and he actually went on to
become the deputy chief historian for the US army and author,
a bunch of books about the war.
But we're going to look at his first book today,
which is simply called company commander.
And he wrote this book just after the war in 1947 and you know,
I get a bunch of books
and I've,
I've talked about this,
like somebody tells me there's a good book out there and I don't even try and
read the reviews anymore.
I just order it because I figure there's a chance it's good.
And then when I get it,
I kind of,
you don't have to crack it open and see if it's the kind of thing that I'm going
to cover that really suits the podcast.
And this book,
I just cracked it open direct to the preface,
which normally I go in the middle somewhere.
I might take a quick look at the preface,
but then I you know,
will look throughout the book and this preface,
as soon as I got the,
I got one sentence into this,
this preface donor,
I said the first paragraph under this,
into this preface and I was like,
okay,
we're doing this book.
So with that let's go to the book and start with a preface.
The once again,
this book is called company commander by Charles Be Macdonald written in 1947
here we go.
The characters in this story are not pretty characters.
They are not even her ROIC if lack of fear is a requisite for heroism.
They are cold,
dirty,
rough,
frightened,
miserable characters,
gis,
Johnny doughboys,
dog faces,
foot sluggers,
poor bloody infantry or as they like to call themselves,
combat infantry men,
but they win wars.
They are men from companies I and g 23rd infantry,
but they might as well be men from companies a and K,
16th infantry or they might be men from company C and e two o 254th infantry for
their stories are relatively the same.
Some may have fought the Germans longer than others or some may have fought the
Germans less for all it was an eternity.
The characters in my story or not fictional and any similarity between them and
persons living or dead is intentional than some of them are dead.
This is a personal story,
an authentic story,
and to make a story of war authentic,
you must see a war,
not a hasty taste of war,
but the dread knowing Daley died of war,
the horrors and fears that are at first blunt testimony that you are a novice
and then later become so much a part of you that only another veteran through
some sixth sense may know that those same horrors and fears are yet there.
I was an officer in the war,
a captain and company commander of companies,
I and g and because I was a captain,
my lot was easier sometimes than that of Joe private and Joe First Class and Joe
Sergeant and even Joe Lieutenant.
But when my lot was easier physically it might be harder mentally because I knew
Joe private and Joe Private First Class and Joe Sergeant and Joe Lieutenant and
I could not suppress my love and admiration for them,
but physical suffering can be worse sometimes and when the Gis lot was harder
than mine.
I shall try and tell you that because I am not the hero of my story.
A heroes are the men from companies I and g,
the lead scouts,
the rifleman,
the machine gunners,
the messengers,
and the more Grumman companies I and g are called rifle companies in the army.
And when you call a company,
a rifle company,
you are speaking of the men who actually fight wars.
I did not fight the Germans as long as some of the characters in my story.
Some of them had been meeting the enemy since d plus one June 7th,
1944 when I joined them in September as replacement company commander,
they'd completed the capture of a stubborn enemy garrison at Brest France.
The day before I joined the join them.
They rested in an open field on the Brittany peninsula for five days and then
they took a train ride on a French freight cars across France to meet the
Germans again.
So there's the preface and you can see when he joins this company,
these guys have already been fighting for over three months,
close to four months when he shows up.
New Guy,
no combat experience.
He shows up and has to jump right into the game.
And here's some thoughts that he has coming fresh from the states company I 23rd
Infantry.
I thought you fought your way assure in Normandy on d plus one you battled to
the hot top of hill one 92 to pave the way for the St Lo breakout.
You storm the ring,
have pill boxes at breast and had your number of Deuce to 50 in the explosion as
the Germans blew them up in your faces and now they give you a company commander
fresh from the states.
They ask you to put your faith in me.
I felt weak and ineffectual.
My mind began to peruse the duties that were before me,
and this is when he's out on patrol.
He's Kinda on his first patrol now in one day and at the most three I would be
leading these men against a team of trained.
I wondered how I would react.
These men deserve the best leadership code I give it to them.
They could boast a glorious combat record already,
and I knew nothing.
Suddenly all my long hours of training for just such a role as this seemed
pitifully inadequate.
If only there were some way I could know just what it was like.
It seems incredible that this group of hardened combat veterans could accept me
as an inexperienced youth of 21 to lead them into battle simply because he
happened to come to them wearing a set of flashy bars on his shoulders.
If only I could look into their minds and see what they were thinking.
Okay.
So you can see this guy's definitely feeling what?
Just about everyone moving into a leadership position and fuels,
which is,
I'm not ready for this and I don't know everything.
And as I've said a bunch of times,
that's okay.
Everybody knows that you don't know everything.
Everything.
Everybody expects that you don't know everything.
What you don't want to do is go act like you know everything cause they're gonna
see right through it.
Hmm.
Now they're,
they're moving a little bit more and
we're starting to get closer to combat.
My pulse quickens.
So this is it.
I said to myself,
using a phrase that every replacement uses a thousand times before he ever
actually reaches combat.
I would soon know if I could take it.
I would soon know if I could justify the faith of the men of company I we
disbursed to our company areas in the darkness,
outside the tent.
I noticed flashes of artillery to the east and the deep rumbling of the big guns
came from the distance.
A voice in my brain kept repeating,
this is it,
this is it.
I stumbled blindly through the dark forest in the direction of the company.
So obviously I'm fast forwarding some stuff here and this is just him getting
closer and closer to going into combat and you know,
every veteran now has that feel of,
you know,
since the wars for us started for,
for this generation star Dove,
this is it.
It's so true.
Everyone's thinking that this is it,
this is it.
This is the big one.
This is,
can I take it?
And so many guys will say that that's what drives them into the military for me.
For sure.
You want that test and there's no,
there's no bigger test then hey there's other human beings that have tried to
kill me and I have to go kill them.
That's,
that's the biggest test of their is.
And guys want to know if they can take it.
Here's some of his thoughts.
Be Calm,
be businesslike.
This is the same as maneuvers,
maneuvers,
just meeting,
training maneuvers.
Give some orders,
start things.
Moving's you're going to have a look at the German army.
So this is,
he's going out on a little
and he now they're,
they're getting in sort of a defensive position here and he says this back to
the book,
I decided to Dispo depose,
dispose my company.
Initially as lieutenant had done,
we could make changes later.
I would've preferred holding one of my rifle platoons and support position.
But it seemed unwise for our company.
Frontage was great.
So you can see he's already listening to like his lieutenant has his guys set up
a certain way.
He's going with it.
He's not going up there and changing everything right away cause he's just going
to kind of set back and see how things go.
Now they're expecting to get attacked,
expecting to get attacked with,
with small arms fire.
But instead it ends up being some mortar fire.
Here we go back to the book,
but the sound of bullets did not come in good.
Stead came the sharp crack and heavy explosion that I knew must be mortar fire
falling behind me.
It sounded as if the shells were falling on the crest of the ridge that we had
so recently left.
But I took no time to look back.
I increased my speed and dived behind a clump of bushes.
There would be no protection protection from those bushes against the mortar
shells,
but I was comforted by their concealment.
I lay there panting,
so here's these in the first contact.
This is it.
My brain kept repeatedly kept repeating madly over and over.
I must not appear afraid.
I must give these men confidence in me despite the fact that I,
they know I'm inexperienced.
They were playing their parts well.
I had been unable to detect any attitude of distrust in their actions and I had
searched their faces for long periods of time.
I must keep that confidence.
I must,
I must scared Campton sergeant savage asked,
so sergeant savages like his senior enlisted guy and he's looking at him and go
scared captain and he says a little,
I admitted I took a long slow drag on my cigarette.
We all are,
we all are savage said we always are.
Pretty a good vote of confidence and you can see the senior enlisted guy trying
to make them feel comfortable with it.
Right?
That's a good senior enlisted guy that's not trying to make it,
not try to go ego.
Hey,
what do you use your problem when you look scared?
You know,
Captain No.
He said,
hey,
don't worry boss,
we're all scared.
No big deal.
We just got to stay professional.
So these guys end up in a,
in a,
you know,
hunkered down defensive position that he's got a man.
He ends up being there for quite a few days where it's,
it's a pill box,
you know,
a bunker and his main control point or command point is inside one of these
pillboxes and they end up with a bunch of guys in this pill box and that he's
got little foxholes dug out away from the pill box where there's a little
platoon guys and squads that are set up in these positions.
And so his task is to maintain the security positions and that's what he does.
Going back to the book,
I didn't plan to sleep at all the first night.
Now that we are in position and the difficulties of moving or moving in no
longer word me,
I was filled with a growing fear that the Germans might hit us with a counter
attack.
I decided that the enemy must surely know that the troops were moving in and
would attempt to dislodge us.
While while we might still be disorganized,
11 men in a pillbox,
11 men who must live from day to day,
never thinking of the immediate future,
but only of the infinity when the war would someday be over.
There was sparky and First Sergeant Alvin savage,
Blackburn Cro to and me.
There was private first class Willy Haggen,
the tobacco chewing 39 year old army regular who kept us laughing with sage
tactical wisdom,
wisdom and served as first platoon runner.
Then there was private first class Angelo Butare of Boston,
second platoon runner who had lost two brothers in the war already private first
class,
Hubert Burger of Memphis,
Tennessee,
third platoon runner who's 18 years old and read his Bible every night.
Private FirstClass,
Caniff Lampton of Detroit,
Michigan weapons platoon runner,
who's also 18 and corresponded with college girls from Michigan and private
FirstClass,
Erling,
g Salberg of Fargo,
North Dakota who is 19 and cleanly good looking and the headquarters Bazooka
man,
the cooks and jeep drivers,
the supply sergeant and the male orderly had been left behind with a service
company to keep us supplied.
The changing of the guard at four o'clock revealed that it was raining outside.
A slow,
cold,
miserable drizzle.
Yeah.
I thought of the men in the forward platoons and they're exposed foxholes with
no protection from the elements except shelter,
half stretched across their holes and nothing between them and the hostile
killers in front of us,
but the muscles of their own rifles.
I had admired the unglamorous infantry soldier before,
but as the rain continued to fall and the night grew colder,
my pride at being a part of this dirty,
miserable infantry knew no bounds.
Yeah.
Now,
like I said,
there was,
he was in this main pillbox,
which it has protection,
right?
It's got a roof and their little bit relaxed in there a little bit.
You know,
they're,
they're protected not just from the enemy,
but they're protected from the elements as well.
Somewhat.
So he goes out and he's going out to visit the guys that are in Fox holes that
are just basically sitting out there bearing the elements.
You know,
like you said,
nothing between them and the enemy,
but the,
the muzzle of the rifle back to the book.
Any idea that I might have entertained that my visit would bolster the morale of
these men's was overshadowed by the effect of visit had on my own morale.
How cool,
how they could smile and laugh and joke in the present condition I could not
see,
but each man had a cheery word for me as I approached,
if I had possessed any misgivings that these men would weaken under the
hardships of their cramped position and the adverse weather,
they faded away into nothing.
Their courage and fortitude made me admiringly envious and brought a lump to my
throat,
so he's thinking I'm going to go out there and boost their morale.
The opposite happens.
He's boosted by seeing them and seeing how,
how intact and motivated they were out there.
Okay.
Back to the book.
As we reached the right flank of the platoon,
I noticed a man huddled in his foxhole,
trembling violently beneath a blanket which covered his head.
The Tena Anti grasped him by the shoulder.
I thought I told you to get digging this hole out deeper.
He said sternly,
the blanket came off the soldier's head.
You're putting me way off here by myself so I can be killed.
He shouted half Sabic you want me to be killed?
There's nobody over here,
but shut up.
Sit.
Auntie said you want the whole Goddamn German army to here.
You get to digging that hole.
There's two men right here with you and the next holes,
10 feet away.
Nobody wants to see you killed.
We turned away.
I looked back over my shoulder at the soldier.
He's been like that ever since.
He's been with the pituitary.
Auntie said uses every excuse he can get to go to the rear.
He won't work to get himself warm like I try and get him to,
if he doesn't come around tonight,
send them back to the CP.
I said we can keep him there for a night and see how he turns out.
So although some guys are clearly
in good spirits out there,
you still got guys that are breaking down and you got to deal with them and you
can see he's going to pull them off the line,
get him back to CP.
And actually I don't go into this,
but he ends up getting evacuated and when they get it back they figured out that
he's got appendicitis.
So he's in,
he's in rough shape,
but so some time passes and you know,
they're dealing with sort of clandestine attacks are coming.
The Germans will kind of pro bono or sometimes they're,
well they're,
they're receiving indirect fire and mortars and artillery on a fairly regular
basis.
Back to the book,
I awoke at 10 for the start of the fourth day in the pillbox.
It was a day of k rations of glorious sunshine,
of adjusting artillery,
fire of testing,
telephone minds after enemies,
shelling of signing ones names to our envelopes of countless letters of
requesting supplies from battalions of one and a hundred things that were
becoming more and more routine.
Yeah.
But always there was the deep fearful dread of the enemy mortar shell that
dropped unheralded from the sky of the artillery round that screeched a fiendish
warning as it approached and the deep dread to of the darkness that would come
tonight,
just as it come last night and just as it would come the night next night and
the next and any night the darkness might release a hoard of fanatical German
soldiers eager to kill and drive us from our holes and pill boxes or perhaps a
flame throwing half tracks spouting it's flaming oily death into the deepest
recesses of the pill boxes.
The nervousness was like a malignant disease that ate itself up and down the
line and back again.
Hear about that stress.
You're about that constant,
constant stress and you notice it's the things that you can't control.
Yeah,
it's the things that you can't control.
That's the horrible things about the the mortar and the artillery fire.
You can't control it.
Just random and you can't control where that round hits.
If it hits in your foxhole,
you're dead.
If it hits three feet away from Your Fox Hole,
you live
okay.
And I think the,
they had these flame throwing half tracks and I think just the,
the,
the to die by burning to death,
everybody knows that's a nightmare.
And so that's creeping in their minds as well.
Back to book,
it seemed that I'd only been asleep a few minutes when I awoke.
The pill box was a massive moving men with apparently no pattern.
A deep dull,
throbbing filled my head accentuated by a fierce pounding that pushed
relentlessly against my temples.
I jumped from the bunk with a start.
The throbbing in my head was a big gun firing the man seated there by the table
is covered with a dull brown dust.
Blood was streaming from a gash in his forehead.
Uh,
tanks firing right at us.
Captain Sparky said excitedly they hit the head,
they hit the shed with a mortar men in it.
Sergeant Paterson got a cut in the head.
I tried to shake the cobwebs of sleep from my brain.
I had been asleep for hours.
It was daylight.
It was eight o'clock in the morning.
I moved over to the wounded man.
He was sergeant Lee Patterson,
a North Carolinian and one of the squad leaders from the mortar section.
The wound is Bree bleeding profusely.
Another man held a handkerchief immediately below it to prevent blood from
running into the sergeant's eyes.
It's not bad.
The sergeant said,
the sergeant said just to cut from some loose brick,
it was flying all around the seller when the shells hit looks worse than it is,
I guess.
So now they're,
they're under attack and you're going to notice a pattern.
I don't know if I'll cover them enough,
but this poor guy,
this poor guy,
uh,
McDonald Cap Macdonald,
it seems like every time they get a major attack he's getting a woken from being
asleep cause he's not sleeping very often,
but every time he puts his head down,
you see almost every time he gets awoken or every time they receive a major
attack it's because he's asleep and boom,
all of a sudden things start happening.
He must've been so paranoid to go to sleep knowing that this stuff was,
was hanging over his head.
So they're getting this pretty cool.
Pretty big coordinated attack.
And then some aircraft show up,
some,
some p 47 shows up,
uh,
like five p 47 shows up.
And here's the description of that.
Each plane circle high into the air and came down with a skill and grace have a
pair of wading dancer upon its target.
The bullets from it's Canon beating a staccato chance of death as it dived on
the Germans below.
Someone behind me said,
oh,
them goddamn beautiful birds.
We watched and silent admiration as the planes climbed once again.
Well their work's done for the day.
Someone said,
yeah,
I'm a mortar man.
Answered reaching for a shovel.
They'll go home now and have a short scotch in a hot bath and shack up with some
Mademoiselle or some Limey wench.
What a life.
Yeah,
and draw double salary for it.
The headquarters man put in,
that's the life for me.
Willie Hagan said,
oh,
dry up.
You never had it.
So good.
So that's,
that's a common thing,
you know.
And we're going to get Dave Burke on here and I'm sure we'll hassle him about
being a pilot.
I mean that is you go,
you do your mission and then you're flying back to base.
The base is our in friendly areas and they're protected,
so you're going to get a short scotch and a law and on a hot bath
and again,
fast forward a little bit and also going back to him being asleep and being
rudely awakened.
Here we go.
Back to the book,
I was nodding off.
I was nodding often as the hands of my watch neared three o'clock awakening each
time with a start and shaking my head in an effort to clear it,
clear the sleep from my brain.
A shot rang out.
It seemed to come from the very entrance of the pill box and was the cue that
set off of a fuselage of small arms that reverberated back and forth among the
hills.
I could discern the slow chatter of one of our heavy machine guns than the
intimidated,
guttural tone of a burp gun.
All the sounds seem to emanate from the area around the farm house as if every
conceivable type of small arms vied to be heard above the company noises.
The explosion of a German type concussion.
Grenade joined the uproar and American grenade exploded and it's fragments wine
through the year.
A few rounds of mortar fire exploded above the din.
I heard the guards scuffle and curse as they tripped on the entrance to the pill
box.
I was suddenly afraid.
I was suddenly more afraid than I had ever been before.
My body seemed weak all over and I wondered if I had the strength to stand up.
I opened my mouth to sound the alarm and I wondered if anything would come out.
Wake up everybody.
I shouted,
surprise that the words actually came forth.
I don't want anybody caught sleeping in this damn pill box.
We had waited long enough.
The Germans had come.
The sound of small continued heightened by the explosions of dozens of light
mortar shells.
Fear gripped my body and left me trembling.
I was not so much afraid of what was happening as I was of the horrible visions
my mind had dreamed up of what would happen should we fail to repulse the
attack.
I visualize the mad dash dash to reach the engines to the pill box to escape and
trap me within only to be met by a hail of enemy fire or a hellish blast of a
flame thrower.
My imagination ran a gauntlet of evil.
So this is a counter attack.
Well,
this is what you've been waiting for.
Now the company veterans,
we'll find out what it has in this youthful,
inexperienced CEO.
Quit shaking.
God dammit stopped trembling all over.
Get control of yourself.
Act like a soldier.
God dammit.
At least you can impersonate.
An officer.
Savage tried the battalion phone,
the handle,
which should have produced a ring,
made an unnatural grading,
sound the lines out.
He cried.
I'll try the other line.
Blackburn,
get your radio set up outside.
So this is despite the fact that they'd been mortared and they've taken some
fire and they've had some little probing attack.
This is the big one.
This is,
this is it.
The Germans had come and it's interesting to hear his thoughts as this going on
and he's tying to tell himself,
stop shaking,
calm down.
Act like a soldier.
Hey,
if nothing else,
just pretend that you're a soldier right now.
Just act like an officer should act right now.
Classic.
So they start receiving this pretty intense attack and he gets on the radio,
eventually get the radio set up and he says,
attack is hitting my left flank and right flank of love company,
their lines must be out to fire us concentration two to one over.
So
what they do is,
and they get in these,
these defensive positions they set up and they have predesignated firing areas
where they can have our friendly artillery or mortars bomb areas.
They already know where they are.
So they,
this one was called the concentration two to one.
That's wherever,
wherever the enemy's attacking from,
they have a name for it.
They say put bombs on two,
two,
one,
boom.
You can get it done really quick.
And it's,
it pretty much,
uh,
almost immediately Holt's this attack.
And
of course that attack goes away.
They kind of get that one under control.
And now he's tired because he didn't get much sleep.
So he goes back to sleep.
And here we go.
Back to the book,
it seemed that I had been asleep for hours when I awoke suddenly with a start,
Sparky's voice came to me.
Some work from somewhere in the distance.
I'm trying to get the artillery.
Blackburn's voice was somewhere else beside it.
Get me Captain Anderson.
Give me Captain Anderson.
But what was the noise in the background?
What was that pounding?
Someone must be beating on the pill box with a sledge hammer.
What was that?
Deafening noise.
I jumped from my bunk.
My feet stung from rough contact with the concrete floor.
That was artillery and mortars exploding,
exploding my head.
I couldn't think.
I shook my head sharply to clear the sleep from my brain.
The Germans had come again.
And what?
Mortars and artillery is good?
God,
they must be firing every weapon round from miles.
There was a wild looking Sparky's eyes.
They've hit all three platoons captain.
He cried head on.
They're pounding the hell out of them.
Worse barrage I ever heard.
Worst barrage I ever heard captain.
Okay.
So like I said,
whenever whenever Captain Mcdonald Falls Asleep,
they're getting attacked and that's what they're receiving really heavy attack
again.
So they repulse that first attack and now they're coming back at him again.
And this time it's with some serious artillery.
For God's sake,
get a some artillery captain.
He cried.
They're knocking the hell out of us.
Small arms and Burp guns and this God damn mortar and artillery fire.
I never saw such a barrage.
We've got to get some help or we'll never stop them.
Okay?
For God's sake,
captain hurry.
Middlebrook said his voice was half frantic.
I got two wounded men here,
my pillbox.
Now God knows how many more are out there.
I suddenly remembered the one 50 fives that close in concentration.
We had zero on our front.
So one 55 is a bigger artillery shell.
It's the big,
big daddy.
And they had,
they had got a concentration of fire that was really close to them.
So Hey,
if we're getting like just about to get overrun,
we can call this this particular concentration of fire,
that close and concentration.
We had zeroed on her front.
What was it called?
Queen one 63 queen wants 63 Oh god,
let us get the one 50 fives
hello.
Tear one,
tear three.
Roger,
tell Tara to give us the one five fives.
Concentration queen one 63 and fast over.
So he calls in that concentration,
which is,
which is really close to them.
You're calling it 150 I think 155 millimeter mortar shell,
I want to say it has like 25 or 30 pounds of explosives in it and they're
calling it a bunch of it.
And here we go.
My heart skipped a beat.
Savage ran back inside to really relay the news to platoons and the big
artillery shells whispered their messages of outgoing death.
Definitely explosions to our front were followed by the noise of shrapnel
spraying the trees around the farm house and small pieces of spent shrapnel
fellow round us.
So they're called those bombs.
So close to third getting hit with the shrapnel from the bombs.
That's how close the enemy was.
And that's how close they're calling these bombs in.
I called for a repeat on the barrage and when the battalion said,
Roger,
we knew,
I knew we had one.
No attacking force could withstand the barrage like that.
So that's a command that you use when you're calling in artillery,
it's called repeat,
which is actually why you never say repeat on the radio.
When you seen the movie,
someone says,
Oh,
can you repeat that?
You don't actually say that.
You don't say repeat unless you're specifically doing this.
Getting them to call more bombs it.
What'd he say then?
Say it again.
I'll say it again.
And so they call these big bombs come in and another couple of days go by.
They end up spending a total of nine days in the,
in the pill box and in that position and who finally they get told,
okay,
we're going to pull you out of the pill boxes and we're going back to the book.
I tried to keep my voice in a normal pitch through the conversation,
but I wanted to jump and kick and scream with joy.
Tears came to my eyes and I thought I would choke with happiness.
It was almost too wonderful to be true.
My battalion runners would arrive around midnight leading the men of company B.
We were getting out of the pill boxes and tonight company I was to be relieved.
So there you go.
Nine days in the pill boxes.
The other company,
company B,
comes out to relieve them and they're doing a a turnover with company B.
So he sent in like one platoon back at a time and he's staying there with the
new company commander who's name is Captain Cowen and we're going back to the
book.
A few minutes later,
call came for captain cower over the platoon phone.
A tenseness came over his face as he answered,
he handed the phone back to the soldier sitting at the table.
They just killed one of our own men.
He said to me,
one of my squad leaders was moving around to the front and was going back to his
whole one of the bar men,
let him have it,
thought he was a German.
I wondered how it would feel to have one of your own men killed by an accident.
Having a man killed by the enemy would be bad enough.
Although I've been mercifully speared that thus far I shuttered.
My men are nervous as hell.
Captain Callen said they've heard all sorts of rumors and stories about these
positions makes them trigger happy.
So we got a blue on blue guys the first night and position and they're freaked
out.
They've heard all these rumors,
they know that these guys are getting pounded by the enemy and the Germans keep
attacking and they'd get so paranoid that they accidentally shoot one of their
own guys.
Now these guys get moved to the rear company.
I kind of get some,
some they get moved back a little.
So a lot of the front line anymore,
and this was kind of an interesting look on that.
It seemed back to the book it seemed now we were in a quiet position.
Every officer in the division with rank of major above wanted to inspect the
company area.
They condemned the men for not having shaved or for wearing knit wool caps
without their helmets.
Evidently an unpardonable misdemeanor or for untidy areas around the dug outs.
These officers did not inspect my first book tune area.
However,
usually passing it over with the excuse that it was a bit far to walk,
but we laughed inwardly knowing that it was the threat of enemy shilling that
kept most of them away.
So,
oh,
you're back in the rear now.
Everyone wants to come and meet you and meet the boys cause there's no danger
there.
Well guess what?
The boys know.
The boys know what's up.
Now he's about to get an order to go out on the attack.
So He's been in an event,
a position.
Now he's moving to TAC,
get set.
It's coming now at the attack order.
At last,
you're going to attack.
There's no chance now for a reprieve.
The CEO of of the 393rd had insisted that we attack immediately to relieve the
besieged unit.
The colonel continued,
but he had succeeded in putting off the attack until morning.
We would jump off slightly before dawn.
At seven o'clock attacking astride,
the East West Highway Company,
I would attack on the left.
Additional ammunition would be available later at battalion.
The platoon leaders were assembled.
When I returned to the company,
I only had one map of the area and there was no place where we could have a
light to examine the map with the lieutenants.
Sergeant Alvin slit trench was deeper than the others,
but that's but,
but at that it amounted to a little more of an than the snow scraped from the
earth and a few inches of frozen earth removed.
The men hastily through dead branches across the makeshift hole and I wriggled
underneath with my map and a book of matches.
One puts one of the platoon leaders,
one by one.
The platoon leaders crawled under receive the order.
I would strike a match and give them a brief glance at the map.
Now wet and sodden from the melting snow.
I wondered if I could have drawn any worse conditions under which to issue my
first attack order.
So here are the,
they'd moved forward,
but now they're getting ready to attack and he's given his first briefing to his
platoon leaders.
He only has a one map,
which is completely ridiculous.
And I think about like every single guy when we would go out on the battlefield,
every single guy would have a battle map.
Every single guy,
if we take 30 guys,
they all are going to have a battle map with them.
So here we are,
we're a old company of 150 guys.
We've only got one map and he's got it.
And by the way,
it's soaking wet.
for your briefing nowadays we go into a big secure area with a PowerPoint and
big projector up and we'd go through all of these slides that are well prepared.
He's got a match in a hole and he's given this brief is what I'm talking about.
So
they end up in a forward position and as this attack goes,
they end up now having to switch from attacking to a defensive position and
things start to get go sideways really,
really quick.
And this ends up is actually the beginning of the battle of bulge to famous.
Obviously a famous battle and this is sort of the beginning of it,
although they did not know that at this time.
So here we go.
Back to the book,
I took stock of our defensive situation.
We were one rifle battalion thrust into a densely wooded area with no terrain
features that favored the defender with orders to hold at all costs.
We were hastily,
Doug in along the highway facing the direction from which we hope the enemy
would come if you had to come.
No company had been able to withhold a support platoon.
There was no support company.
Thus the defense was thin,
single line of riflemen so there's no backup.
That's the situation.
They're in a shallow draw laid to the front of my rifle platoons with a higher
ridge rising beyond it over which the enemy would soon becoming.
Another draw led up to my left flank,
protected by two light machine guns and a few riflemen and position which no man
in his right mind would place machine guns unless he had no other method of
defending the probable enemy approach.
These guys are in a horrible situation.
Our right flank lacks our right flank,
lack 50 yards of tying in with k company along a firebreak which bisected the
highway.
We had no anti-tank defense except to Sherman tanks and a bazooka with three
rounds of ammunition.
We were being supported by 99th Division artillery and outfit about which we
knew nothing except this was their first action except for holding a quiet
defensive sector for a month,
but there was nothing that could be done now,
but wait at 10 30 a jeep loaded with men clip down the highway toward the rear
at break neck speed.
That would be the vanguard of the retreating battalion from the 99th the Germans
would be here soon.
Just imagine that you're there to help out and defend this position and support
this battalion.
And the first thing you see coming from ahead of you is a jeep filled with rag
tag soldiers going as fast as they can away from the enemy
craziness,
craziness.
And here it continues.
A ragged column of troops appeared over the wooded ridge to the front of the
second and third platoons.
There were not over 200 men,
the remnants of 900 who had fought gallantly to our front since they were hit by
the German attack the preceding day.
Another group the size of a platoon withdrew along the highway,
donating a few hand grenades and clips of ammunition,
which they pass to f my first platoon,
two men stayed to fight with my company.
It's a legit,
you just got overrun.
Some guys are given away ammunition given grenades away and these guys are,
hey,
where can I help out
to enlisted men carrying a badly wounded lieutenant stopped exhausted with my
third platoon.
They could carry him no further.
I called for a litter squad.
The rifleman could not be sure if the next troops that appeared over the ridge.
We're friendly.
Your enemy.
I alerted the artillery men to call for fire.
In the event the approaching troops were German.
Lieutenant Brock's call came a few minutes later,
scarcely proceeding a hail of small arms fire,
which sounded like the crack of thousands of rifles echoing through the forest.
There was no doubt my men could see the build caps of the approaching troops.
They were Germans
and you know,
we're going to get to a point as I go through these books and I highlight little
sections and I read that little section.
I'm about to get to a point here shortly where I'm just going to read the whole
damn section because it's,
it's so much.
It's a company that's about to get overrun,
right?
It's a company that's about to get overrun by Germans and it's,
it's really interesting to hear what this looks like from the company commander,
company commander's perspective.
But this is,
I mean,
this is it.
This is,
you're losing the battle.
I mean,
he survives,
but it's,
it's as bad as it gets.
It's as bad as it gets back to the book.
Any me bullets whistled through the trees around us.
I jumped into the slit trench with savage and Blackburn.
Request after request for artillery and mortar support came from the platoon
leaders.
I called for every concentration listed on my overlay and for variations of
each.
So that little thing I was talking about where you're calling for these
concentrations,
you've got two to three and this one and that one.
He's just calling for all of them.
Call them for all of them cause bomb everything.
The inevitable maddening three rounds fell each time.
So they're trying to conserve in the rear.
They're trying to conserve,
conserve ammunition.
So the lead,
you're finding three rounds at a time and he's do it again,
do it again,
do it again.
But platoon leaders begged frantically for more.
I began on one side of the company area and called for concentrations all across
our front and back again.
Lieutenant saw,
you're called for barrage after barrage of 81 millimeter mortar fire.
The crack of small arms reached an ear splitting crescendo,
crescendo like static on a forgotten radio during an electric storm.
I lay flat on my back in the slit trench that will tune phone to one year.
The receiver of the battalion radio on the other,
the chill from the frozen earth seep through my clothes and I shivered.
But I was surprised at my own calmness.
The long nights of shaking terror and the pillboxes convinced me that I would
never be calm and combat.
I did not know what possessed me to keep calm.
Surely this is the most serious situation which I had ever found myself.
The small arms fire reached another crackling,
crescendo,
Crescendo.
The small arms fire reached another crackling,
crescendo long had several men wounded long as one of the other commanders.
He didn't know how many or how badly the enemy bullets were too thick to move
around.
We're too thick to move around.
I called again for litter squads.
Wave after wave of frantically screaming German infantry storm.
The slight tree covered rise held by three platoons.
A continuous hail of fire exuded from their weapons answered by volley after
volley from the defenders,
Germans fell left and right.
A few rounds of artillery.
The few rounds of artillery we did succeed in bringing down caught the attackers
and a draw to our front and we could hear their screams of pain when the small
arms fire wood slacking,
but still they came.
Artillery and naval war refers,
which is like another kind of Canada German cannon with their accompanying
terrifying screams,
played a deep accompaniment in the background.
The shells exploded to our rear and around the road junction to our right.
We ignored they're crushing explosions,
thinking how thankful we were that their effects were reserved for others than
ourselves.
The small arms fire rose and fail again and then again indicating that the
attacking troops withdrawn momentarily to the bottom of the draw to regroup
before launching another suicidal assault reinforcement streamed over the ridge
behind them to join the assaults.
The draw and the highway were littered with their dead and wounded,
but there seemed to be no end of their fanatical attacks.
Second Platoon reported as company soldier killed.
It was the first death and company I since I had taken command three months
before,
but the news was not so staggering as I had expected it would be.
There was too much other excitement.
The dead soldier was technician fifth grade,
Martin w Carlson from Pennsylvania.
He was an aid man whom the rifleman idolized who had jumped from his foxhole to
aid a wounded soldier nearby,
a bullet pierced his helmet and he fell face forward into a hole of the wounded
rifleman.
He had sought to aid.
He was a noncombatant according to the rules of warfare and was denied the
privilege of wearing the combat infantry men badge and the $10 per month pitons
for dangers and hardship endured,
but death made no distinction.
Message after message came over,
the platoon phone,
Lieutenant Wilson was badly wounded.
He could not walk and must have a litter.
Ammunition was running lower and lower.
The [inaudible] company machine gunners with the first platoon were out of
ammunition except but enough to keep one gun firing a few minutes longer.
The 60 millimeter mortars found their ammunition supply so low that they fired
only when the enemy was actually assaulting.
Germans were being killed as close as 10 yards forward of the foxholes.
Hand grenades were practically all gone.
Yeah,
this is,
this is it.
There was no solace from the battalion,
each call for litter bearers or additional ammunition.
It was met with the maddening words we're doing all we can.
I told them we could not hold out much longer unless we got additional
ammunition.
Captain Montgomery said,
we must hold.
Our orders are to hold that all costs.
He said,
I wondered if he could possibly realize the meaning of those words we must hold
until every last man was killed or captured company eyes last stand
and what is to be gained.
Nothing but time.
Time born of the bodies of dead men.
Time.
Okay.
Seven times the enemy infantry,
assaulted,
and seven times they were greeted by a hail of small arms fire and hand grenades
at sent them reeling down the hill,
leaving behind a growing pile of dead and wounded.
But with all the attacks seem poorly organized.
There was no supporting artillery or mortar fire on our positions and I wondered
why they had not yet found the open flank on our left.
There was only the suicidal wave of fanatical infantry men whooping and yelling
and brandishing their rifles like men possessed.
I looked at my watch,
it was three 30 in the afternoon.
Time was passing amazingly fast,
long again,
long was the,
uh,
was one of the other platoon commanders.
Long said he saw enemy tanks.
There were five of them.
Giant Tiger's lung blurring down the road,
300 yards away,
surrounded by over a hundred and enemy infantry men.
Get those Sherman into action.
Sherman,
who was our,
our us take,
get those Germans into action.
It's your only hope you might,
he's talking to himself.
You might hold off the infantry even with your ammunition,
practically exhausted,
but rifleman can't fight tiger tanks.
The first platoon has,
you're only three rounds of Bazooka ammo unless the Shermans can stop them.
Three rockets are all there is between you and company.
I and kingdom come.
So small arms.
Obviously machine goes,
they don't do anything to attack and they only had,
there's five enemy tanks coming and they only have three bazooka rounds,
which a bazooka rounds can stop a tank,
but you know,
you got to hit.
It's got to be a good hit and all that.
So he knows he's in big,
big trouble.
I called Sergeant Garcia to send a man to contact the tankers and tell them to
move immediately to their foreign positions on the left flank.
This business of improved positions with so much Bosch Garcia,
his answer was stunning.
They're gone.
Captain,
they pulled back to k company 15 minutes ago,
so he's expecting the Sherman tanks or to be help out,
they're gone.
I did not take time for the full meaning of his words to sink in,
giving our,
giving her a call,
sign over the radio.
I asked Colonel Tuttle and told him my plight.
Either I get those tanks back to my left flank or I could not possibly hold the
position while waiting for the colonel's answer.
I tried barrage after barrage to destroy the Tigers with artillery and mortars,
but we made not a single hit and the near misses only stopped the infantry
temporarily not phasing the great steel monsters in the least they wattled
effortlessly on toward the hapless riflemen around of 88 millimeter snapped from
the top,
snap the top from a fir tree above our heads and fragments sprayed down in all
directions.
There could be no doubt.
Now the Tigers had arrived round after round,
crashed into the area,
a momentary shrill whistle followed by Daphne explosion and a sharp thought of
the round being fired the ladder reaching us after we heard the shell explode.
For God's sake,
captain long screamed over,
the phone is half voice.
Sabic get those tanks down here.
Do something for God's sake.
These bastards are sitting 75 yards away and pumping ADH into our fox holes like
we're sitting ducks for God's sakes.
Captain,
what about Your Bazooka?
He said a bullet had gone in one and and bent the tubes so the rocket would not
pass through.
Okay.
Colonel Tuttle was on the battalion radio.
The tanker said it would be suicide for them to face the tiger tanks.
They would not move unless he gave them a direct order.
And then he was afraid they would disobey it.
Okay.
And he was inclined to agree that they stood no chance against the more heavily
armored tigers and the 88 so these American tanks or they can't fight against
the Tigers.
And so they're backing up so that they can survive.
I burned with anger and I must have been insubordinate if my men could fight the
armor plated monsters with nothing but rifles and die in the attempt to tankers
could afford to try it with medium tanks.
If we don't get the tanks,
we can't hold another five minutes.
I said slowly and finally,
thank you Sir Roger Out.
And for those of you that don't know,
I've explained this before,
out means you don't need to talk back to me.
You don't need to.
I'm not requesting a response out means I'm done.
I'm hanging up the radio,
which is interesting that normally the the junior person,
the says you know over and it's the senior person that says,
Hey,
don't talk to me anymore.
I'm done with you.
So he's saying to the,
to his leader,
he's saying,
if we don't get the tanks,
we can't hold another five minutes.
Thank you,
sir.
Roger out.
Okay.
Shades of general Custer company,
eyes last stand.
Hell.
What does it matter?
You never expected to get out of this war alive anyway.
Not really.
I gave long the news.
He was frantic.
There was absolutely nothing he had his men could do a direct hated landed on
one of the heavy machine guns.
Another it hit the technical hit.
Technical Sergeants,
smiths,
Foxhole Smith was the platoon sergeant long.
Didn't know if he was dead or not.
The other machine gun crew is out of ammunition and was withdrawing.
He was powerless to stop them.
He was afraid his left flank and the draw was falling back,
but he couldn't see to make sure hold long.
I cried for God's sakes.
Hold.
We've got to hold.
I wondered how I made my voice so convincing.
I wanted a throw away.
The platoon phone and the battalion radio and everything connected with the war
and bury my head in my hands and cry.
Cry,
cry.
Yeah.
The infantry assault upon the other platoons continued.
The sound of the battle reached a height which I had never thought possible
before.
The burst of the 88 millimeter shells in the woods vied with the sound of
hundreds of lesser weapons.
It couldn't last forever.
I thought it must stop sometime.
It must stop,
but when and how?
I looked toward the draw between me and the highway,
about 20 men were walking down the draw toward the rear.
I recognize several men from the light machine gun section and a machine gun
crew from m company.
The other ones were riflemen from first platoon.
I did not know where they were going.
All I knew is that somehow I must stop them.
I jumped from the slit trench and ran toward them ignoring the crack of bolts
through the trees,
waving my arms and shouting for them to stop.
They turned to look at me with vague blank expressions.
They seem to wonder who was this crazy man who wanted them to do this foolish
thing.
I saw that it was the entire left flank of first platoon.
The thin lines of the remainder of the platoons would soon be cut off from the
rear.
The 60 millimeter mortar man of few words away,
a few yards away.
We're dismantling their weapons.
I managed to get my mood to get the men to move to my CP,
but I could not step them that,
stop them there.
They walk slowly on towards the rear,
half dazed expressions on their faces.
So his guys are leaving and he's doing what he can to get them to stop and
fight,
but they're,
they're leaving.
This is,
it's not happening.
The guys know and,
and they're out.
I mean,
they're out of bullets right there out of bullets.
They don't have any ammunition left with nothing to do,
so they're leaving.
I jumped into the slump slit trench and grasped the radio handpiece.
I sat on the edge of the trench ignoring the whistle bullets and the crash of
[inaudible] 88 millimeter shells around us as everyone seemed to be now doing
get the platoon leaders on the phone.
I called the savage
Hello Roger One.
I said it to the radio,
not waiting for my acknowledgement that they were receiving my message.
This is Mac.
My left flank has fallen back.
I can't stop them.
The Germans are overrunning my left platoon.
I'll try to build up another line along the firebreak.
We can't hold here.
There I had said it.
This was I company turning tail and running.
This was I company retreating.
This was I company hauling ass.
This was I company running like a son of a bitch.
Strangely,
I didn't give a damn.
I was utterly void of feeling savage held the platoon phone towards me.
I can't get long.
He said,
and he's here with us now.
Don't sound afraid.
You've got to sound like you mean business.
Hello Brock.
I said calmly,
they've overall longs position.
Swing your platoon back to the left rear and we'll build up another long along
the firebreak.
Did you get that?
Garcia pull back and we'll tie with K company.
My CPS pulling out now we've got a hold of the fire.
Blake,
do you understand that we've got to hold the firebreak the men in my CP group,
we're already moving towards the rear.
I grabbed my,
my musette bag and my car been savaged took the phone,
Blackburn grabbed the radio.
We ran toward the rear.
We reached the north South firebreak and crossed it.
The foxholes.
Which battalion did aqua occupied.
We're fall along the far edge of the clearing and a patch of small firs who's
interwoven branch has formed a small dense green barrier.
I knew that any fight here would be at close quarters because the Germans would
be able to advanced unseen to the edge of the firebreak 15 yards from the
foxholes we would occupy,
but it was the only spot where we had to,
any possibility of holding.
I ran up and down the line shouting,
we've got to hold them here.
We've got to hold them here.
The men stared back at me unbelievably.
I was asking headquarters men armed with carbines and pistols to hold off a
hordes of attacking Germans that had already broken through all our rifle
platoons could offer.
There was only one machine gun,
a light gun man by Private First Class Richard Cowan of Wichita,
Kansas set up five feet from the Fox hole,
which I occupied.
The Germans were almost upon us before we knew what was happening.
We could not see them for the low hanging branches of the fir trees across the
firebreak,
but we could hear their shouts and shrill whistle signals,
which evidently came from their leaders.
I decided they were flanking group that was on its way unseen around our left
flank.
Even as we left our former CP,
the attackers who had dislodged first platoon could not have reached us so
quickly.
Cowen began to spit machine gun fire across the north narrow firebreak and I
heard German heard a German scream with pain.
The headquarters men fired their carbines and pistols into the low hanging
branches.
The fir trees to the right were too thick to see the area where the rifle
platoons were supposed to be going into position.
I wonder if they had been able to build up any semblance of aligned around.
Came from an enemy tank,
broke the top of the small for tree above.
Cowens had sending him reeling from the gun,
but he jumped back and continue to fire.
I knew that the big tigers had reached the junction,
the firebreak and the highway.
Hails of enemy bullets thrashed the snow and the fur and the trees around us.
The fruit trees around us.
I ducked beneath the cover,
my foxhole trying to get battalion on the radio,
but without success I stood up and looked out of the whole great God.
There was no one left,
but Cowen,
the others had fallen back.
I jumped from the foxhole and yelled,
the count,
withdraw savage and Blackburn followed me.
I left my my set bag lying on the ground,
but my car been was over my shoulder absent mindedly.
I screamed to get the radios.
Savage,
jumped back into the foxhole and Blackburn and I turned and plunged through the
thickly interlace branches of the little first.
Bullet's followed us lashing the first on all sides and I wondered if maybe I'd
been hit.
I felt no pain,
but I could not see how any human being could endure those handles of bullets
and not be wounded.
I stumbled blindly through the brush on heedful of the branches scratching at my
face and hands.
My overshoes were slick and I tripped and fell face downward in the snow.
I rose again and stumbled on blindly as we punched through the first.
I was separated from blackbird and the group that had held held briefly at the
firebreak.
I did not worry that savage or the others were not with me.
They were at someplace else in the fir thicket.
I came across Sergeant [inaudible] and Sergeant Walter l Dietrich of Cincinnati,
Ohio or machine gun squad beater.
We plowed through the first together until we came unexpectedly upon Ks,
k companies CP,
a series of half completed foxholes dug in the frozen red earth.
Okay.
Captain Howard see Wilson of Houston,
Texas.
The K company commander was talking frantically over 300 radio.
He turned as I approached,
damn,
but I'm glad to see you.
He said,
battalion lost contact with you and I haven't heard anything about how your
company's coming.
He seemed more leave than perturbed at seeing me and I wondered what he thought
brought me to his CP.
Perhaps it was the way I stood looking at him blankly.
There must have been nothing in my face to tell him that my company was no more
and that even now hordes of Germans were rushing toward us unchecked.
Okay.
Through my mind raised only one thought I had failed and failed miserably.
My orders had been to hold that all costs and I personally had failed and
because of my failure,
the entire,
the entire battalion would be routed or annihilated it all from a local German
counter attack.
I company had fallen back,
but I could not blame the men they had given in because I had some way not led
them correctly.
It was I who was responsible.
I would turn in my captain's bars if I ever reach the rear or perhaps they would
court martial me.
I did not care.
There's nobody on your left flank.
I told Captain Wilson in a matter of fact,
voice that I hardly recognized as my own.
They just knock the hell out of us and the whole company's falling back.
I couldn't tell you where any of I companies right now except these two
sergeants and myself,
good God,
what can I do,
Mac?
I don't know.
I said,
you can't hold here.
There's nothing on your left
and then it continues.
My platoon has fallen back.
He cried.
It's those God damn tanks.
Yeah.
I said I had three rounds,
Bazooka ammo and then knock the bazooka out.
I've got sicked rounds.
Six rounds.
Captain Wilson said two men grabbed a bazooka and disappeared into the
underbrush and the direction the enemy.
I thought how foolish it was to think of stopping 10 tiger tanks with one
bazooka.
The two soldiers returned a moment later panting for breath.
Good God,
captain and one of them said the woods just a few yards away from here off full
of the bastards.
We better get the hell out that settles it.
Tell your other tunes to withdraw and to Creek Elton rocker shelf.
Notify Battalion.
Tell them we're getting the hell out.
We plunged again through the thick fur trees towards the rear.
I heard cap.
I heard battalion on Captain Wilson's radio telling l company to withdrawn to
Rosh wrath before the full force of the enemy's flanking drive could hit them.
We reached the edge of the patch of small firs to our left.
Lay the explodes to highway leading up the hill into Roger Wrath to our right.
The corner of the firth thicket joined the corner of a patch of larger trees
which extended out 200 yards up the hill.
We chose the louder route without hesitation.
We ran halfway through the patch of woods before we came upon a group of
abandoned foxholes.
Captain Wilson yelled the group to the Holt will hold up here.
He shouted.
We may be able to hold them up for a while while some of the others get out.
I could not see what good we could do from this position,
but I was taking commands now and I took cover alone in a fox hole and the edge
of the woods facing the highway.
It was good to let someone else do the thinking for awhile.
Even if I disagreed with the decision,
I was not afraid.
Instead,
I was strangely apathetic to the whole affair.
The Germans were hot on our tails,
so what?
They'd been a hot on my tail for almost as long as I can remember now,
and they had cut my company to ribbons.
They might as well get me too.
German infantry men who emerge from the thicket.
We had left such a short time before and milled around to us,
abandoned US tanks parked in the open beside the forest accompany and machine
gunner private first class Jose M.
Lopez of Brownsville,
Texas.
Set up his gun beside a hole five feet to my rear.
He opened up on the German infantry with the blast of muzzle,
the blast of muzzle forcing me to sink to the bottom of my whole for cover.
The Germans wasted no time in returning fire.
Riddling the area around the machine gun in my foxhole with a burp gun and rifle
fire.
A Tiger tank appeared at the road junction where where the battalion had been
shelled the night before and fired.
Point blank at Lopez is exposed position.
The long barrel of the 88 on the tank seem to reach half the distance from the
hole to my foxhole.
Lopez continued to fire
and American jeep with two aid men.
They're red.
Geneva crosses,
painted on their helmets,
tore down the highway from the direction of Rosh giraffe toward the road
junction.
I held my breath.
The Tiger tank would surely blast them from the road.
Couldn't they see the Germans were here.
Now they did with the jeep spinning on two wheels.
They turned around and tour back up the road.
The tank did not fire
over the noise of Lopez,
his machine gun.
I could hear the Captain Wilson shouting to withdrawn to Roger Breath.
I wanted to obey,
but I was caught in the crossfire of the heavy machine gun and the attackers.
I gritted my teeth and waited for a Lola in the firing.
None came.
I jumped from the hole and ran blindly towards the rear bullets,
snipped at my heels.
The tank saw that we were running again and open with renewed vigor.
The big shells snapping the tops from the trees around us as if they were
matched sticks.
But I saw no one fall dusk was approaching and it was difficult to see for any
great distance.
I could not make out the town of Rochester f that I knew it was high on the hail
to our left front,
but we plunge blindly up the hill falling the thin hedge row that would be scam
protection against the Germans should the Germans elect to follow us with fire.
I slipped and fell down,
fell face down in the snow.
I cursed my slick overshoes I rose and fell again.
I found myself not caring if the Germans did fire,
snow had gotten inside my shoes and my feet were soaked,
my clothes were drenched per perspiration covered my body and my mouth was dry.
I wanted a cigarette.
I felt like we were helpless.
Little bugs scurrying blindly about now that some man monster had lifted the log
under,
which we had been hiding.
I wondered if it would not be better to be killed and perhaps that would be an
end to everything
and that's the,
that's the section right there that like I said,
I mean you just can't,
I couldn't skip anything in there.
Just too much stuff going on and to hear what it's like from his perspective of
being overrun and they continue to fall back as fast as they can and they're,
they're basically at an every man for himself.
The for yourself situation at this point.
They finally do get back and he ends up in sort of a compound and he tries to
find his battalion commander and so he does.
Going back to the book.
We walked across the courtyard inn down the dark steps of the house into the
basement.
A group of enlisted men were eating k rations.
Colonel Tuttle was quietly talking to a group of officers.
A dim candle lit the room.
Nice work,
Mac.
Colonel Tuttle said,
I couldn't control myself.
I could control myself no longer the choking sensation in my throat became
racking sobs that I could not hold back.
The colonel tried to comfort me and I felt foolish and childish,
but I could not stop.
Someone gave me a cigarette.
I held it with trembling fingers.
I was suddenly conscious that Colonel Tuttle was saying something to me,
but at first I could not make any sense of what he was saying.
This had been no local German attack.
The enemy had already broken through and taking bull again,
catching the division quartermaster and the engineering troops unaware in the
undefended town.
The main supply route for crinkled to the rear through Bergen had thus been
severed.
The two other battalions of our regiment had been thrown into the battle and the
division was abandoning all its gains in the offensive to hold this critical
area.
Our battalion had held long enough for the ninth and 38th regiments to withdraw
past the vital crossroads guarded by two stone farm houses that I remembered
from the trip forward.
The ninth was setting up a line along our present location and the 38th had
taken over the defense of crinkled.
There were unconfirmed rumors that this was a big German push all along the
first army front.
The news stunned me,
I stammered.
You mean you mean?
I mean,
you did a good job,
Mac.
The colonel said,
the Germans are throwing everything they've got.
You held out much longer than I expected after I learned the true situation,
so I had not failed and I company had not failed.
I was almost happy that the German offensive was a large scale one.
My men had done an excellent job against heavy odds and those who had died,
we're not dead because of some personal failing of mine.
The realization made me want to cry again.
I still did not know what had happened to my company.
So like I said,
this was the,
this was the massive,
massive German counter attack that he happened to bear the brunt of the
beginning of the battle of bulge and well,
you know,
you can hear clearly.
He just thought,
I just,
we just,
it was a local little German attack and we folded,
but it was a massive German attack and they put up an incredible resistance.
So now he starts,
he links up with savage sergeant savages is senior enlisted guy.
He sees him back to the book,
savage and I ran for each other like two college girls suddenly reunited,
smiles,
read dark faces.
We both tried to talk at once.
He'd heard that I'd been killed.
I had not known what had become of him.
I jumped back when the foxhole after you said get the radios.
He explained at length.
First thing I knew there were Germans all over the place.
They made me come out and took my watch and,
and moved me over to the highway where they had two other gis.
Then one of our artillery barrages started falling.
The crowds hit the dirt.
I grab one of their burp guns and started spraying and we ran like hell.
All three of us got away.
So that's,
that's how savage got out of there.
And a little more time passes.
I began to evaluate our losses in the fierce opening day fight in the,
in the Korean kilter evolved.
Initially approximately 80 men were listed as missing,
but each day brought a new list of names from the rear hospitals of men who had
been wounded in evacuated or were victims of trench foot bliss.
The list of missing in action finally narrowed down to 24 men.
So even though you know they lost control and he didn't know who,
he didn't know where,
where everyone was.
I mean they were just gone.
He was the only guy that he was alone when he came back or Oreos with one or two
other guys.
So that's out of 150 guys.
So eventually they realize or he comes to,
there's only 24 guys that they don't know what happened to the rest of them.
The rest of God out of there.
Okay.
And this is what it looked like.
Overall back to the book,
our battalion was awarded the distinguished unit citation for its defense in the
crank crank helter walled.
And a number of men in the company were awarded bronze and silver stars for
Gallantry,
including silver stars for Lieutenant Golfing gun and me.
All those were posthumous awards.
Private First Class Cowan,
the light machine gunner who had performed his duty so faithfully and fearlessly
at the firebreak was killed in action the next day.
But he received the distinguished service cross that was later changed to the
metal of honor and private FirstClass Lopez,
the m company Machine Gunner attached to k company also received the nation's
highest soldier honor the metal of honor.
So in that one defense,
these guys,
you know to medal of honors given out unbelievably.
Now this is also kind of crazy.
So you go through that,
right?
You go through that,
you,
you lose a bunch of guys,
you barely make it out,
your company's overrun.
Well guess what?
It's not over.
He's guys are right back at it again.
And the next thing they're at is they are,
they get tasked with doing another tax so they do recover a little bit,
but they're getting told,
okay,
you good?
You got you got,
you got assembled again.
Okay,
we got more work for you.
One of the men of woke me at six o'clock I blinked my eyes several times and
tried to realize where I was.
The realization came and with it a feeling of revulsion that the war still went
on and today we would attack.
I wanted to turn my face back toward the wall and sleep on
and they're planning this attack.
I was too busy with the various details of the movement to think much about
fear.
I tried to recall the various phases of an attack that I had learned in
training,
but I was fully conscious of my lack of experience.
So even after all this,
he still doesn't feel like she's experienced enough.
I looked at my watch,
it was 15 minutes until four o'clock the artillery barrage will begin in five
minutes l company.
He was moving into position now the time was drawing near Oh God.
Be with us on this attack so the nerves don't go away.
When we reached the railroad track,
the first and second platoon's jockeyed in a position in the open field,
they moved quickly into an approach.
March formation,
small explosions that sent the snow cascading in all directions and little black
puffs of powder and noise appeared on pattern over the field.
The men fell face downward into snow and rose again with a barrage lifted.
The Germans were firing light mortars,
one man from the second platoon lane,
a crumpled heap and did not rise.
His face was buried impassively in the snow.
I looked at him as I passed.
He was a new man,
a replacement received the week before.
He was the first man from the company who might seen killed and a mixed feeling
of honor had pity swept over me and it mixed feeling of horror and pity swept
over me,
but there was no time to stop and think.
I didn't even know the man's name.
How strange is war?
Some of us can go for days and weeks and months in war and never be killed or
wounded.
But another man is killed and his first taste of war.
So as they're doing this attack,
is a little tactical advice here from,
from sergeant savage.
Goddammit.
Captain Savage said,
you've got to stay further back.
At least get some scouts out in front.
His admonition reminded me that it was foolish for me to lead the column,
the foolish days of leading one troops into battle.
We're passed even though correspondence persisted in telling of daring generals
who preceded their troops firing from the hip or brandishing a band net.
I had no feeling of bravado,
but it seemed obvious that the woods were undefended.
I dropped back to the rear of first platoon.
So leadership position tactically,
if you're too far forward,
number one,
you might get killed.
Number two,
you might just end up in a firefight.
We're now you can't move and you can't make direction.
You can't even talk on the radio cause you're,
you're in the firefight.
Fast forward a little bit and they're in a,
in a big firefight,
a burp gun stuttered,
a float of fiery tracer.
Bullets blazed along the trees.
We fail,
fell face brown downward into the snow.
The bullets traced a fiery path two feet above the ground.
My men did not return fire and I was glad the confusion would be terrific if
they opened up.
The night was quiet again.
I rose in motion for savage,
Sahlberg and Charles to follow.
We had taken only a few steps.
When the BURP gun opened up again,
I'm hit captain.
I heard Charles Scream and he dropped into this snow.
I'm hit.
I was conscious of a sudden pain in the calf of my right leg as if someone had
hit me with a giant club swung by powerful arms.
I realized that I too was hit and a sudden flood of fear and Gulf to me.
We were 200 yards forward of any friendly troops and 800 yards inside the woods.
A momentary vision of a night spent bleeding in the frozen forest,
swept through my mind,
a warm liquid float over my leg and into my boat.
That would be blood I fought.
I'm hit to Charles.
I said my leg felt numb and I dropped the ground.
The firing ceased.
Charles said he was hit through the right hip and could not walk.
Savage took the battalion radio and I designated two men to carry Charles.
We would have to get back to third platoon.
Now I believe that could walk.
I just do it and put weight on my wounded leg.
A nauseated pain swept over me and I thought I was going to faint,
but I tried keeping the leg stiff and found that I could walk.
The men around us lay flat on the snow in little bunches as if gained some
solace through sharing their fears with each other.
My brain was whirling.
Should we continue the attack?
How badly was I heard?
How do we hit a German patrol or an outpost outpost or stumbled upon a main line
of defense?
I hastily decided to continue to the rear out of the line of fire of the direct
attack upon the German position from a less respect,
restricted spot,
we moved toward the rear two men supporting trolls with his arms about his,
with his arms,
about their shoulders,
a sudden burst of small arms.
Fire came from our right rear and the woods echoed to the crack of machine gun
rifles.
The fire was coming from the direction of the defensive position at the junction
of the firebreaks,
which we had left bullets wind low over our heads and buried themselves into the
trees and snow around us.
My first thought that was was that k company had contacted our rear elements and
thinking they were Germans had opened fire.
We heard battalion talking on the radio asking k company what they,
what time they wanted to pick up their bed rules for the night.
We've got no use for bedding roles.
K Company answered,
it was Lieutenant flame.
We're in a firefight.
Savage turned the butterfly switch on the radio and broke the conversation with
the distressed voice.
Lieutenant flame.
He cried,
Lieutenant flame,
this is I company.
You're firing at us.
This is item company.
God dammit.
I said,
we're in a firefight.
We can't use any betting roles.
Now,
lieutenant flames savage continued.
This is savage.
You're firing it.
I company make your men quit firing.
You're firing an I company.
You're shooting the hell out of item company.
The radio was silent for a moment.
The hell we are.
If we're firing an eye company,
then why in the hell don't you quit firing back?
I was frightened with the realization of what he had said.
We were receiving fire from K company,
but they were not firing at us.
The enemy had slipped behind us for an for some unexplainable reason.
My men had not opened fire and either a directions from which the bullets came.
I thank God that they had not started shooting.
The confusion would have been trebled and I could visualize gis firing at one
another in the darkness
as the worst case scenario.
You got bad guys in between you and other good guys.
It's,
it's just a horrible situation and he,
I maybe,
maybe it's hard for civilians to understand this.
When you're in a firefight,
you're not hitting all your targets.
You're shooting suppressive fire and so if I'm shooting in one direction,
the bullets are not stopping where the enemy is,
they're going to keep going indefinitely,
you know?
So if there's friendlies behind the enemy,
you can't,
you basically can't shoot.
You basically can't shoot.
So He McDonald gets,
they continue on,
he continues on for a while trying to get them in a secure situation,
but eventually he has to get extracted because of,
because of his wound and he gets back
what he gets.
He's now like under warm blankets and stuff and they're these in the aid
station.
I shuttered at the thought of the company.
Where were they now?
Did Brock's platoon get out?
Had I done the right thing and withdrawing or should I have stayed and fought it
out?
It seemed that I was always running.
Perhaps it was all my fault.
There had been a brief moment of exfiltration in the aid station when someone
had reminded me that now I could a nice rest in the hospital.
But now a nausea fear for the welfare of the company envelop to me.
I felt somehow like a dessert or,
yeah,
you hear you.
We've heard plenty of stories about guys looking for the million dollar wound.
It's going to get them back to the states and the million dollar wounds good for
about three minutes.
And then,
then,
then Mcdonald's says,
Hey,
I feel,
I feel horrible.
He eventually recovers from the wound.
Now you'd think,
hey,
you know the guys but thought a bunch of fighting.
He recovered from his wound but he got wounded.
But now he's in the rear and so you know,
he's probably gonna get whatever extracted,
maybe move to states,
maybe,
you know,
give him a nice cushy job.
No,
not happening.
They don't give him I company back cause I company now as a new company
commander,
they give them a company G.
Hmm.
So now he's in company Ge and what are they doing?
Are they in the rear somewhere relaxing?
No,
it's attack time there going forward.
So here we go.
We were back to the book.
We would attack the next morning at four 45 someone awakened me at three 30 the
next morning it was cold in the room and I shivered.
As I climbed from my sleeping bag,
my mind was doled with sleep and I wanted to climb back into the warm sleeping
bag and sleep on and on.
I wanted to scream to hell with the war and go back to sleep.
The sudden jolt of awakening was like emerging,
emerging from a wonderful,
peaceful world into a world of forbidding reality.
There'll be mad hurt today,
perhaps killed men from my own company.
It could be me that seemed remote and impossible,
but it did not remove by fear for the others.
There were many responsibilities.
Had I given the platoon leaders all the information they would need.
How was my attack plan?
Was there some important detail I'd forgotten?
Would Haim back be defended?
Would our attack be discovered as we crossed the flat open field towards the
town?
Oh God,
if we could,
but rush from the house into the attack without thinking again,
it was the waiting and the thinking and wondering that got you
talked about that before.
That fear that you're feeling.
It's the waiting.
It's the hesitation and he's saying,
Hey,
if we could just go from this house that I'm sitting in right now,
right into the attack.
That's what he'd prefer to do,
but he can't
and now they're moving to the attack is,
is,
is full on now the last man in the Ford positions crossed the crest of the small
hill.
They should be almost inside.
The first house is a Bendorf.
Now I thought,
I hope that the CP group and assump can trail running across the crest of the
hill and told junior to ask for reports from the assault platoon.
Suddenly a tank fire from somewhere to a front and a big show,
a shell word over low over our heads and machine gun.
Chattered around of tank fire.
Rip from the limb,
from a tree above our head.
A burp gun said Burp,
burp.
There was no question.
Now we had hit their defenses,
the Germans to had techs.
I was trembling slightly from the excitement,
but I was not as deathly afraid as I had once been in a pillbox positions.
The opinion often expressed amongst some gis that ev after any man was wounded
once he was never any good in combat.
Again,
did not hold true.
In my case,
I was more calm than ever before,
but I was also more cautious.
Now they proceed with that attack in it again.
Obviously
there's this book is just filled with tactical situation after tactical
situation,
after lesson learned,
after lesson learned after tackle situation,
and I'm not reading the entire book right now.
Uh,
but that is why you get the book so that you can get all this information from
it.
I can't give it all to you on a podcast.
You have to read it.
But fast forwarding through that assault,
back to the book,
I stopped longer at the house where the men from the squad of the sergeant who
had been killed.
We're preparing for the night.
I not knowing the sergeant personally,
but to these men,
he was an important character in the little war that revolved around themselves.
There was an undertone of sadness as they talked,
but there was no bitterness.
The sergeant had died,
like any one of them might die at any time.
There was a war on,
you know,
and what I like about that is he points out that,
okay,
you know,
from his perspective,
all this stuff is going on.
He realizes that these guys,
that's the whole world to them,
right?
That sergeant that was killed,
that's their guy and their war is everything to them.
And it's just like when you meet people,
you know,
if you're in a business and you go and meet someone on the front lines,
like they don't care.
I'm not saying they don't care,
but they've got their whole world in what they're doing.
So you gotta be cognizant of that.
You got to understand that and you got to keep that perspective.
When you go out and talk to people,
you can't be like,
oh,
you know,
hey,
there's a lot of people that got killed today.
No,
it doesn't matter to these guys.
The only one guy that matters to these guys
now,
like I said,
this book is covers a ton of different combat and they go while he's in charge
of g company,
they go through all these different towns.
I mean they go through the town of hom breasts into across the Vesta river and
they go through El House and they go through Var Lawson and they go through
varmints in and they go through mangere housing and geese smart and they're
going just from,
from city to city.
They're going very quickly and the fighting,
it's becoming a little easier as they're going the defenses and you know,
the Germans are running out of,
out of people they're running out of um,
you know,
supplies as well.
So the fight is getting easier,
but they're still meeting some hardcore,
some hardcore defenders.
And one of the things that's happened that's really horrible is the,
the,
the Germans now are using anti aircraft weapons against the ground troops.
So anti aircraft weapons make flack that goal for the year and they explode and
they are now using those against the ground troops.
And there's a,
it just the way that these browns are coming in and exploding above them.
It's a nightmare and it's really hard for them to fight.
So they've got some good efforts going on to go and take out these,
these anti aircraft weapons and one of the,
one of the anti or one of the groups of anti aircraft weapons that they take
out,
they finally get,
they finally take out these anti aircraft weapons through an assault.
And when they get done with the assault,
Mcdonald comes up on the position and here we go.
Back to book Sergeant Patents said the Germans manning the position in the
field,
which held them up were bastards.
They had to AA guns.
He said some of them wanted to surrender,
but every time a crowd would jump out of his hole to surrender,
some other crowd sob would shoot him right in the back counting the ones they
killed.
And the ones we got to.
There's 19 dead patent had one man slightly wounded in the arm,
but he had already walked back to guys more to,
to the aid station.
My weapons platoon and platoon of heavy machine guns from h company arrived from
there supporting position outside guys.
Mark Sargent Mark Mitchell was killed.
One of the sergeant from the heavy machine gun told me,
I could not think of for a moment who sergeant Mitchell was that I remembered.
He was the pleasant perennial,
cheerful tech sergeant and command of the platoon who was to receive as
commission as a second lieutenant in a few days
and anti
aircraft gun fired from the woods to the south.
The sergeant continued and Sergeant Mitchell got hit.
He was unconscious and the aid man took him back to one of the tds to give them
first aid.
Td is a tank destroyer.
It's like another tech,
but they're specifically meant to fight other texts.
The aircraft gun fired again and the God TD backed up ran right over Sergeant
Mitchell.
So that's uh,
another thing that
you have to train for is when you're working with armor where you were working
at the tanks,
they don't know what's going on around them.
They don't have like a rear view backup cameras.
And so if you get in the way of a tank,
it's gonna run you over.
And so that's something that we,
we,
we were lucky when we,
before we went on deployment,
we'd go work with tanks little bit.
And that's where we'd learned that lesson because you might think all take cover
behind this tank,
that tank could move at any moment.
So you gotta be very careful of that young troopers out there.
If you don't work with tanks often stay out of their way.
Here's a,
as they're continuing to press through and press through and press through from
village to village town to town again,
they're moving pretty rapidly.
Now
back to the book,
Colonel Smith rolled up beside me beside my tank and his jeep.
Nice going Mac.
You said you're doing a really swell job.
Just keep them moving.
The faster the better.
Don't thank me colonel.
I said,
meaning it and disgusted that it sounded melodramatic.
Thank Lieutenant Bagby and the first platoon,
I'm just tagging along.
So you got a leader there that's not looking to grab all the credit himself but
give it to his troops.
Now,
like I said,
both the fighting
continues to get easier and easier and they're starting to see,
you know,
people surrender.
They're also starting to see like young kids because you're starting to see the
Hitler youth that are being recruited.
They're 13 years old,
14 years old.
Kids that are surrendering,
they fight through core Beth and low pittson.
Craig's dwarf,
and I apologize for my lack of German,
um,
speaking capability,
but they get,
they get into one town and one of the lieutenant's Lieutenant Whitman kind of
pushes into the town with a small team and he's in there,
he's in one of the buildings and all of a sudden,
like a massive group of,
of German soldiers comes in and they're kind of stuck there.
So here we go.
Back to the book.
Lieutenant Whitman called suddenly over the radio and I knew by the excitement
in his voice that something had either happened or what's about to happen.
You better get somebody else up here to help us out.
Sounds like a whole regimen of crowds coming are common this way up the highway.
So this,
he's trying to figure out what's happening.
And then the radio sputtered hello,
g g six this is wit.
So g six is the call sign for Mcdonald's.
Hello g six this is whit.
For God's sake.
Get someone up here to help.
There's Germans all over the goddamn place.
I grasped the speaker from West Miller's outstretched hand wit.
This is Mac.
I said they caught us halfway across the open field.
The men have taken off.
I'll have to go back and get them to come up over for God's sake.
Get us up some help quick.
We're completely surrounded Roger out.
So now Whitman's in one of these buildings completely surrounded.
This continues on.
The battalion radio was silent.
I called for Lieutenant Whitman and his voice came through weekly as though he
were speaking in a stage whisper back on the left side of the highway.
He said,
in a house,
I've got nine men with me.
Germans are running all around,
all over the place.
I lost track of all the other men heard some of them surrendering,
get us some help quick or they'll find out where we are when they start
searching the houses.
So Mcdonald tries to okay calls battalion,
Hey,
we needed some help.
We need some help here.
No,
you don't get any help.
And so he tells Whitman or Whitman,
here's one of the radio that he's not going to get any help.
He's not getting any support and this is what Whitman says,
there's only one thing to do.
Then he continued.
If we have to wait that long,
they're sure to find us.
We'll go down to the cellar and you start plastering us with artillery fire.
We're inside in.
The crowds are out in the open.
We'll help you direct fire from here.
I knew his decision called for a generous amount of fortitude,
even though he would be partially protected in the cellar.
Lieutenant reads set up as artillery radio and artillery gave us a priority
mission.
Sergeant Barnes arrived with his platoon and the machine gun section.
I sent them into position along with a heavy a platoon of heavy machine guns
from age company to hell with the ammunition.
I said,
we'll get more from somewhere.
Spray the hell out of the whole area.
The machine guns opened up and artillery whistled overhead thundering into the
open field,
dangerously close to the paling fence.
At the end of the garden,
300 short lieutenant reedy yelled and do his radio.
300 short,
the artillery whistled overhead again.
Employment into the houses beyond us with a terrific roar.
Orange flames let the darkness like flashes of lightning that's right on top of
us.
Co Whitman cried,
delighted,
let her go again.
We can hear Germans running all over the place outside.
Lieutenant read called for barrage after barrage and the big shells roared into
the objective.
The Germans made feeble efforts at retaliation with their machine guns,
but the shots died away in the explosion of the big artillery shells.
A direct hit transformed a house into a massive roaring flames.
Is that your house?
I asked Whitman half fearfully.
No,
seems to be on our left.
He answered,
gave us another volley in the same place.
Sounds like a tank or some kind of armored car pulled up,
but 10 of read called for a repeat volley that hit just right.
Women said his voice,
scarcely audible over the radio.
I wondered what had happened to his radio and was afraid that perhaps the
batteries were going dead and we would lose our only means of communication.
I can't talk loud.
He said,
I've got 15 crowd prisoners down here in the cellar with me and some Germans
have come in upstairs.
We can hear them walking around.
If one of these prisoners so much as opens his mouth,
I'll plug him.
Okay,
so there's another situation where you're calling in artillery to your position.
You just happened to be in the seller of a house.
Crazy.
Here,
they're,
they're doing a little assault and it's set up like a frontal assault,
but he wants to make a little adjustment here.
The obvious solution to being unable to advance frontally against the unseen
enemy was to send a flanking platoon around to the right,
having them enter the woods and come out,
come in on the defenders from the flank and rear.
But I balked at the thought of sending one platoon such a great distance when
for all I knew the woods beyond the canals might be thick with enemy.
I decided to cover our front with artillery and have two platoons try to advance
frontally and notified.
Second and third platoon is to be ready to move forward under cover of artillery
barrage.
But the enemy came suddenly delight when the rifleman rose to go forward and
repulsed three efforts to advance.
So he wants to flank,
but he's weighing it in his head.
The the flanking positions through the woods.
In order to flank,
he needs to put his guys through the woods through an area he doesn't know,
doesn't know how well it's defended.
So he says,
you know what?
Instead of doing a flank,
which is what I want to do,
I'm just going to put down some artillery fire and we're going to do a frontal
assault.
They get shut down and eventually he does make the decision.
You know what the bet the decision now becomes,
okay,
frontal assault is not going to work.
Now I'm going to have to flank.
He goes back to that flank.
I sent Whitman with a spare 300 radio in order to across the canal.
He moved out quickly and far to the right.
I could see as men emerged from the woods and weight across the first canal,
the water coming to the next of the shorter men.
My fear of a larger enemy force in the woods overcame my fear for safety of our
left flank and I ordered lieutenant bag beets platoon to follow the flanking
force.
We could see the little dots that were Whitman's man emerged from the woodline
and double time towards the garden.
Lieutenant reads stopped the artillery fire.
The third platoon to my front began to advance and I knew it was only a matter
of minutes until the objective would be ours.
I singled the CP group and we moved to the railroad tracks on the and on toward
the bridge pass.
Three wounded Germans line helplessly in the goalie beside the tracks were
Barnes mended evidently shopped them earlier in the day.
The automatic,
the enemy,
automatic weapons suddenly opened up again at the third platoon,
but the men were close enough now to pick up the bush from which it was firing.
They fired round after round into the clump of bushes and the weapon was silent.
So eventually he gets his flake on and that's what,
that's what wins the day.
Now again,
a lot is covered as they do this city by city.
Some of villages,
some of the towns that they enter,
there's no resistance.
Some of them there is massive resistance.
They pushed through it,
they fight through it,
lots of lessons learned,
lots of incredible heroics,
and eventually they pushed through and they make it all the way into
Czechoslovakia.
And we're now approaching the end,
not only for Mcdonald,
but at the end for the war as they go into liberate.
Check is the you going back to the book,
our column continued forward and my company shifted to the lead position on the
tanks I wrote behind the lead tank in the artillery jeep.
The little country towns changed into industrial small industrial towns and we
began to notice a scattering of red,
white and Blue Czechoslovakia and flags in towns in place of the usual white
flag of surrender.
Civilians waved at US guardedly from behind closed windows.
The scattering of check flags should have warned us,
but we were totally unprepared for the mad celebration which greeted us in the
next town.
We had suddenly crossed from the Sudeten land into Czechoslovakia proper.
The houses were a riot of color with red,
white,
and blue,
Czechoslovakia and flags.
Civilians line the streets 10 deep cheering and waving their flags as if their
lives depended on it.
Our column was forced to slow down and the happy civilians pushed into the
street and showered us with flowers and cakes and cookies.
One old woman throws to bake chicken to our jeep.
Another old woman's stood behind the road beside the road,
waving both hands in the air,
tears streaming down her wrinkled cheeks.
Little children were wild with joy.
Some of them had never known anything but six years of Nazi occupation,
okay?
The young men wore red,
white,
and blue arm bands and carry German weapons are part of the underground movement
that was now,
it was even now struggling against superior German forces in the capital city of
Prague.
Everyone was screaming the check words Nazar Nazar and we wondered what they
meant.
I looked up and down the column at the soldiers and the company,
brilliant smiles to read their faces and they waved cheerfully at the shouting
crowds as if they had just won an election campaign.
And this was a personal triumph hardened stubble faced bedrooms had on shame,
tears in their eyes.
The unleashed joy of these oppressed people knew no bounds,
and it was too much for us.
Okay?
Suddenly I began to realize what no one thus far had been able in the war to put
into words what we were fighting for
and I found a lump in my throat,
which I could not swallow.
Freedom.
Okay.
Something we take for granted.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
the news came by radio,
not the war was over.
There was no defining our joy.
Sergeant Quinn brought out a treasured keg of Cognac.
The next day,
May 8th would be v e day.
The town's people held a dance for us.
The next night in the town guesthouse,
one of the artillery men was escorting a young girl whom he had met the night
before and she told him that her friend leap
would like very much to attend with the captain.
The small guest house was crowded with dancers and the older men and women sat
with the young children at tables around the sides of the room.
Male dancers,
the male dancers were predominantly Gis,
but if you chuck check young men were present.
The Orchestra reminded me of the circus bands in the u s as they played the
waltz,
the Polk us.
The checks would join it off and to sing the songs enthusiastically.
Even as they danced
at the insistence of the band leader leap,
a grantas agreed to sing and the new notes came forth in a clear sparkling
soprano.
When she had finished,
she made a brief speech,
which the Slavic speaking soldier told me,
said that the people would now sing their national anthem.
He would be the first time they had sung it in public.
In six years,
the people rose as one and every boy,
girl,
man and woman join in the singing with clear lusty voices that made goose
pimples rise on my arms.
Okay.
Some of the older people cried and it was all I could do to keep the tears from
my eyes.
When it was over,
the soldiers began to cry.
Speech,
speech,
and the civilians caught on and applauded.
I stood up on a chair in the center of the room trying to think of something to
say or mumbled,
a few of sincere gratitude for the wonderful reception these wonderful people
had given us and a soldier translated for leap that she told the people what I
had said.
They applauded warmly.
Okay.
Leib and I walked outside into the cool night air in the distance.
We could see fireworks exploding in the air above Pilsen and we knew that they
too are celebrating v e day.
Yeah,
I looked around me and saw light streaming from the windows and army vehicles
driving on the highway with their headlights on and I heard the gay music and
laughter from the dance in the background.
I suddenly realized that I could light a cigarette once again in the open and
not be afraid of drawing enemy fire.
And I did
okay.
It was a simple thing,
but it gave me a wonderful feeling that life was worth living again.
I put my arm or about leaves waste and she pointed to the multicolored fireworks
display and laughed.
Dole,
Bree,
Doh,
Bri.
I had learned that debris was good and I said,
don't worry,
don't worry.
I looked away in the distance and I seem to see the faces of the men from
companies I and g who could not see this great day because they had died to
obtain it
and then their faces were gone.
And I saw the mud and ice and snow of the secret Siegfried line.
Then the exploding fireworks became bursting artillery shells and the are dense
and bursting flack at be pets.
But then,
okay,
the terror was gone and I saw two companies of men marching by and there was I
company and Ge Company,
tired,
dirty,
weary but with smiling faces and somehow the faces of the men who had been
killed.
We're in the background smiling and waving bravely to those who marched on
leave looked up at me as if to ask what I was thinking and I said,
don't worry,
dope,
worry
and lead squeezed my hand and laughed.
Yes.
Dope.
Bri,
that is the end of my story.
Or perhaps you would like to know that my company moved on five miles north of
Pilsen to trim Olsa.
And there we met another group of dirty,
tired infantry men who called themselves Russians.
A month later,
we were on a big boat at [inaudible] and on July 20th,
1945 we sailed into New York harbor and received the cheers of a grateful
America and saw tall lady with a torch that brought tears to our eyes.
The characters in my story,
we're destined to be sent to help to finish on another war.
And another part of the world where another group of American infantry men were
fighting a dirty,
miserable war.
But a miracle happened and the other war came to an end.
Most of my characters are wearing civilian clothes again now,
but I know that wherever they are,
they will have a hollow place in their hearts for those who will not be changing
into civilian clothes again,
ever
those Gis who that others may live
or cut down
in a harvest for the devil.
Okay?
And that
is
how this book wraps up.
Incredible book again.
It's called company commander.
Bye
Charles B.
MacDonald and
gold,
though that is the end of this book.
Let it not be the end of our memory
and let us not forget these lessons and let us not forget the tyranny
and the oppression that was forced on to millions and millions of people
and let us not forget the millions and millions and millions of innocent people
murdered,
butchered,
frozen,
starved,
wasted,
wasted human lives
to satisfy the twisted ego of a few.
And let us never forget these men.
Okay.
That fought hunger and fatigue and fear
to face and to fight evil.
Let us not
forget those that sacrificed their youth and their health
for the youth and the health of others.
They finally let us never ever forget those men and women
who were cut down in this harvest for the devil to give other human beings the
most precious gift in the world.
Freedom.
Okay,
let us never forget them
or this gift
freedom.
Hey,
do I think that's
all I've got for tonight?
Echo.
Charles,
if you want to maybe take a minute here and explain,
give me a chance to decompress over here and maybe you can explain in the
meantime if somebody wants to support this particular podcast.
Sure.
How they could do that.
It's crazy.
These books that don't
like the effect of any,
obviously you didn't read the whole book,
but
okay.
Just what you read.
Like the way it affects you,
you know,
it takes you there and just even like at the end when it's like the war was
over,
you feel all your like,
oh my gosh,
thank God that's over kind of thing.
You have that feeling and it just never wears off.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Well I've said before,
you know when we,
when we started and I wasn't sure if I would have enough books,
right?
Yeah.
But we're going to have enough books.
Every single one of these stories is,
is its own incredible story.
And,
and,
and because what we just talked about,
how you get this,
this war,
World War Two for this guy was bisque here.
But you know,
you get someone that's in the Pacific and you take one.
If you were to take one of his platoon commanders,
it would be that war.
It's little tiny human experiences that are so incredible.
And each one of them is as just as incredible as the next one is just as
incredible as the previous one.
And that's why you just,
I,
I just don't know if we'll ever get to them all.
And the other thing is that we have to remember is a tiny,
tiny,
minuscule percentage of these people actually wrote a book.
Most of these stories,
they just,
they just happened to him and we don't know about him.
Yeah.
So crazy.
And each one is like,
it's so unique in their little perspective,
but at the same time it has so many similarities,
you know,
and it all sorta like,
as you gather,
you know,
one story,
two stories,
all these different,
it starts to tell this overall tail,
you know,
and this is the tale of,
of humans.
It's a tale of human nature.
It's a tale of,
and it's the tale of overcoming,
right?
Yeah.
I mean just the things that these guys that were coming to take all these
things,
you know,
I've been,
I've been in some miserable places right in my time,
right?
I mean,
every,
basically everybody has,
you've been at some hard places in your life.
And then these guys,
they do that and they live that way.
And then they get attacked and then they lose guys and they get wounded and then
they'd go right back out.
Right back on to the front.
The limits of human nature or the limits of human,
the capacity of human beings to overcome
obstacles is,
is,
is unbelievable.
And if there's nothing else,
like I,
I know not everyone goes to war and not everyone should go to war.
And I don't want anyone to go to warf can help it.
But at least we learn that whatever we're coming up against,
man,
we can deal with it.
We can do so much more and be so much more uncomfortable and push yourself so
much harder.
And you know,
that was one thing and I didn't,
I didn't do a good job today of portraying it,
but he's getting pushed.
And a lot of these situations,
I mean you can kind of hear it when he's getting woken up.
Every time he wakes up his and his initial reaction is,
isn't cool.
I get to go fight now.
No.
His initial reaction every single time is like,
I want to go back to bed.
I want the war to be over.
I want to hide.
I want it.
That's his reaction every single time.
And yet every single time he gets up and he does his job,
he does his duty and he does what he has to do.
That's,
that's the human spirit,
right?
That's the thing that we should all capture.
I mean we have a hard time getting out of bed because it's going to be a tough
workout or cause we're gonna have a hard day at the Avinu.
We have the second week we're,
we're,
we're pathetic.
We're pathetic compared to these guys that are,
oh it's,
you know what's waking you up?
Mortar fire,
no machine gun,
fire people screaming that they're being overrun.
That's your wake up call.
I think we can get out of bed in the morning cause we,
you know,
cause we got it,
we're facing a tough workout or a hard day or we've got to get up early for
travel or whatever situation you're in.
You can do it.
I can do what we can do it.
Look at what these guys went up against day after day,
after day,
after,
after day after
day after day.
Just doesn't stop.
It just doesn't stop.
And the whole time,
by the way,
there's the threat of death by the way.
The whole time freezing.
You know,
I just thought about this like this is a book where he doesn't even talk about
like his family.
Yeah.
He doesn't talk about his love when he says not done know he's there.
He's just like detached from everything else.
He's got award it,
he's got a war to fight.
So thankfully we get these incredible memoirs.
This one here,
if you're looking at it on Youtube,
uh,
holding up the cover,
I got the old school version,
it has illustrations in it.
Got some cool ink drawings of it's all of weapons just to kind of let you know
what these things look like,
but incredible stuff,
man.
So yeah,
support,
right?
If you're in the mood.
Yeah.
Like for instance,
how much effort does it take to click through Amazon?
It does take a lot of,
you could do it if you want to support,
if you want support in that way.
Actually,
Dina,
hell,
let me go ahead and explain that.
The Amazon thing is cool.
So
you do you Amazon shopping like we always do daily for some of,
uh,
instead of going to straight to Amazon,
just go to Jocko,
podcast.com little Amazon banner on the side.
You kind of got a scroll down if you want to hit the banner sometimes,
but I put it up in the top menu as well.
Boom.
Click on the Amazon banner.
Dan,
do your shopping.
Good way to support.
Like chuck was said,
just you know,
little actually do that if you want to,
if that's what you're doing.
If you're supporting the podcast,
are we asking them to assault a target?
Are we asking them to flank and enemy or we,
are we asking them to come up against Panzer tanks or tiger tanks with one
bazooka in 10 days?
No,
no,
no one's asking for,
I let us have porch.
It's a good way to,
it's really good way.
It's,
well,
I was going to make the comparison to the plane that comes in and then lease,
you know,
but meanwhile it's huge support.
But that's true.
Let's face it though,
those pilots,
that's death.
That's a lot of work for sure.
I mean,
I don't know if that's a fair comparison,
but nonetheless,
let's stick with sodium on that one.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like sodium,
you know,
little B sodium,
throw it in the fish.
You know what?
We should actually do that.
Yeah.
We need to do it.
Actually.
We need to do Facebook live.
We need to get some sodium and put it in a bucket of water so we can give
visuals.
Yeah.
Good.
Behind the situation that you're talking about.
Yeah.
We'll do it at your house.
Okay.
Bring it.
Where did he get sodium?
I Dunno.
Like cvs.
You're the logistics guys.
Go get some sodium.
Look into that one.
Anyway,
that is a fair,
more fair analogy.
You're the sodium,
big reinforcement effects with Amazon.
Click through situation.
Also,
if you're into supplementation,
which I'm going to go ahead and recommend it now kicks me three years ago and
you're not going to hear me recommending any supplements.
Maybe it preworkout maybe,
and even then it's like caffeinated.
I was thinking you don't care.
So on it,
right.
That's the supplements we're talking about.
If you didn't know
if you did know,
this is all familiar to you,
but the preworkout that we talk about,
it's called total strength and performance.
You know,
weightlifting and whatnot.
It's preworkout.
It's not,
it's stimulant free.
Right.
So you know what I was thinking?
I was like,
hey,
stimulant free.
Preworkout is kind of different than what I'm used to be.
You know what it's like,
I don't,
but I forgot a few of them.
But it's like,
it's like you ever watch movies and the good guy,
like,
I dunno Clint Eastwood,
he's all calm.
He's like,
he's not wired and he's all calm,
but one it goes down,
brought,
he kills,
you know,
kicks ass.
That's what this pre workout is kind of like.
Like when you take it you're like,
oh I'm calm,
but on the inside so much protect and then when you get the work going it's like
boom.
So that they do studies on on it.
That's actually the good,
one of the good parts about it is like they do real like placebo test it like at
studies double blind placebo testing and stuff like that.
Sounds cool.
But it is cool.
So with this pre workout one,
it's like over,
I think it was like a four week period,
it's like,
oh I want to say 6% improvement on like on air about,
you know,
and I'm thinking,
oh yeah,
6% was say,
okay cool.
Single digit percent.
Sometimes that can mean a lot.
So I'm like thinking,
okay,
what's 6% what does that look like?
You know?
So I'm thinking,
add that to your bench press number or whatever,
but this dead lift number,
subtract it.
So this is,
this is how it really needs to be negative.
But I know rob,
because I'm trying to prove up a real legitimate point.
Okay,
so let's say I'm doing some dumbbells,
right?
I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to do a set of 10 on,
and I'm not saying me,
I'm just seeing anyone and I'm going to use the hundred pound dumbbells.
I'm going to do 10 of them curls,
we'll do,
how about this?
We'll do a bench press dumbbells and I'm 201 week I do,
you know,
set a 10 boom solid,
right?
And then whatever.
I finished my workout the next week,
if I can do 6% less,
like that's my limit.
You know,
I'm,
I'm feeling 6% weaker.
I can't do those hundreds of 10 times.
No,
I got to go to the 95 bro,
you know,
whack.
That is a real way.
So I'm saying if you don't take this pre workout over a month period of time,
this is just on average.
If you don't take this pre workout,
you're the guy who did the 90 fives if you do,
you're the guy who did the hundreds.
Actually it's less than 95 is really,
it's like 90 fours really on average.
Dang.
See,
so that's what if you're not taking the pre workout,
which I do now,
by the way,
if you're not taking it,
you're that guy.
No offense.
I mean that's cool,
but I'm just saying you're missing out on gains.
Go Laura.
You know,
you can see what I'm saying.
Anyway.
And this is all proven stuff.
This isn't just me making it up.
It's like proof they do.
They did Florida State University against.
We'll see for yourself.
Yeah.
That part is up to you.
I mean it's,
it's up to you to go get after it.
You know?
What about you personally?
Yeah,
I'm all up at fall upon it.
I didn't measure my results or nothing like that.
I didn't just do double blind.
Yeah,
the pop remember.
Oh that's right.
Pop is real.
How they did it is,
you know,
you know even the word double blind,
placebo,
placebo situation,
whatever.
Like a lot of people,
they didn't know what that is.
What it is is they get a bunch of a group of people who are going to work out
hard,
going for gain straight up.
They're going to give them all the supplement,
all of them,
all of the people that are going to give this supplement.
But half of those people,
it's actually not the supplement.
It's like nothing,
but they don't know that everyone thinks they're taking the supplement.
So they're all getting after it.
They're all,
you know what I mean?
And then they say,
okay,
who's going to who,
who's gains are better?
And they monitor and all the people in the supplements,
their gains where you know,
on average and it's all these different lists,
back squat,
all this stuff.
So boom proofing.
Anyway,
it tastes good that much.
I can actually attest to,
he does.
I was thinking about,
I can attest that it makes now I can't,
I haven't done a double blind placebo on myself.
I mean,
because I'd have to like mix it up and fake myself out.
I'm pretty hard to track.
But like I said,
I,
when I,
when I feel the need,
I take not only shroom tech sport but also the pre yeah.
And get after it.
Yet,
if I know that the boys are waiting for me for those you shit to training.
Yeah.
And I know it's going down.
I will.
If I'm not,
if I'm feeling any sort of hesitation,
I'll get after that.
So felt aggressive when in doubt.
And it makes sense too because obviously Jujitsu specially when you're going
hard,
that's a workout that you need to recover from and you'll be,
you know,
so you'll get better results from recovering from even a Jujitsu workup.
You know,
I just worry about performance performance.
I'm not doing it for recovery to be honest with you,
with the Jujitsu workout.
But like it or not,
that's what you're getting
fully,
fully is well,
but yeah.
So good.
Yeah.
You said it tastes good.
It does taste good.
It was weird because,
um,
as far as pre workouts go,
like if you get a regular quote unquote regular preworkout,
they tried to make it tastes like candy and Kool aid and lemonade and all this
stuff.
And I'm not mad at it.
It tastes good or whatever.
But yeah,
man,
let's face it.
I mean this is good.
So when I took this one,
it was kind of,
it had more of like a,
um,
you know,
like if you take like natural greens or something,
it kind of has those,
yeah.
Earthy,
earthy,
earthy.
There's earthy flavor to it,
which I was like,
oh,
this is different.
It's not like candy.
And I was like,
okay.
And then after a while you kind of get used to it and then you have that,
you know how you have that association to certain tastes from like,
then you go work out,
you get the pop in.
It's kind of part of the routine.
So it's like,
tastes all good now.
You know what I mean?
It's like through association.
Yeah.
Good.
Anyway,
it doesn't taste like Krill oil.
Like if you're chopping,
chomping Krill oil tablets.
Yeah.
You got to just swallow.
Those don't jump.
Those guys did not taste good.
Yeah.
So then cool.
So krill oil,
speaking of which is the go to in my opinion,
it's the go to,
I was talking to Greg train about what's today.
It was yesterday I was talking about.
And of course like okay,
if you're working out and you're like,
hey,
my joints are less sore,
that's good.
Of course.
But you don't,
when you do notice it,
and in my experience even more if you pay attention is like for example,
like a few days ago,
I'm sitting down in the living room with the kids.
You know,
we're seeing,
we're sitting there for a long time,
same positions,
like for 45 minutes,
usually after 45 minutes.
And then said,
okay,
it's time to get up.
Whatever you gotta do something,
you get up and you're like,
ah,
you know,
you get up,
and you make that noise mean no.
But if I didn't take Krill oil,
I probably would have that.
And I have had that,
especially if you've worked out that day or something like that.
You know,
you just stiffen up.
I'm just saying,
then you feel it with the Krill.
It's almost like you're always warm,
not warm physically,
but you know,
like you've already warmed up.
That's kind of what you feel like.
It's good.
I'm a supporter.
Yeah.
So I'm saying get the Krill oil.
Like I said,
I had injuries and Cro oil.
That was a long time ago.
Then I started taking her a lot and I haven't stopped in,
I'm not going to,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause even like,
like you say,
injuries,
which yeah,
of course legitimate,
but I never,
I mean I've had injuries but
it more helps like the pre injury,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Something that's just Kinda just nagging you.
You know,
stuff you got to like battle through or something like that.
You don't have to battle through that anymore.
You got Omega threes.
Excellent.
Next time I'll go into the whole white fish oil or Krill oil is better than fish
oil because we talked about it.
It'll take too long.
It's kind of technical.
I'll put it into layman's terms some of the time.
Anyway,
Krill oil is dope.
Preworkouts dope.
Everything on it is good.
Actually,
just depends on what kind of workout program,
what kind of lifestyle,
you know.
But they have something for everybody,
like regardless of what you do,
even the Krill oil,
even if you're not that active,
it's just good for your joints,
you know,
as like,
because over overtime you degenerate,
you know,
whatever.
Krill oil regenerate.
Also another way to support his subscribe on iTunes or the various podcast
platforms.
Google play,
all these things.
If you subscribe,
if you haven't already,
you know,
that's the good support,
get updates when new episodes come out.
Also on Youtube,
we have a youtube channel,
excerpts on there along with the video version of this podcast,
which helps if you need to know what echo looks like.
Because apparently echo does not look like what he sounds like.
Yeah.
I've been told actually,
how's this?
So Paul
knew friend Paul came in from Arizona,
visited,
came to the v victory,
looked into some Jujitsu on that.
I was out of town.
You're out of town.
Yes.
To too bad.
So he goes,
he says,
when I walked in,
he's like,
Hey,
echo.
I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
And he goes,
Oh,
you're for some reason I thought you'd be bigger.
He said,
I was like,
oh,
interesting.
I will say,
because typically people,
if they haven't seen me or whatever,
they think I'm smaller and you think I'm bigger.
So it's kind of,
it was just different.
He probably got that impression from reading on social media.
That echoes Jack.
Maybe a little echoes jacked or,
yeah.
Or maybe,
you know,
maybe he thought I was just taught like super tall or something.
Oh yeah.
Well maybe,
but you,
what are you,
five 1160 11
super tall.
I'm normal height.
I Dunno.
Either way.
Um,
what was the point there?
Oh yeah.
If you want to watch youtube videos of,
of Jocko.
Yeah,
it's less about me,
I think.
Oh,
it's about,
it's about me a little bit.
Yeah.
So either of us.
Um,
and you want to watch a video version?
Go ahead.
Watch that man.
It's good.
It's on youtube.
And also,
uh,
I'll put some excerpts on there.
It does,
it gets you to want to watch the whole cause to sit in front of the computer and
watch like for two hours,
three hours sometimes.
I mean,
that's kind of unrealistic unless you're allowing me to do it.
Yeah.
Well,
no.
What,
what,
and I've done this before too,
you just put it on like your TV,
the smart TV.
Sometimes I want to see what is going on in the podcast.
I want to see the look on my own face or on your face when I say something,
I Kinda wanna see what that looks like.
Yeah.
And that makes sense,
because when you figure,
I mean,
I feel like a lot of people will watch less TV,
but that could be just my little bubble.
But no one watches TV.
If we,
oh yeah,
I don't want to stall.
No,
but think about this.
Yeah,
that's a good for sure.
But let's say you watch it.
I Dunno,
Dr Phil,
not that I watched Dr Phil,
but if you watch that,
that's all they're doing.
They're sitting,
this guy's talking to this person and you're just watching it.
You could listen to that.
You're saying,
and I'm just saying if you're in deductr fill that,
the difference between looking and and watching it and just listening to it,
like you understand that people actually do watch two people talk about stuff.
It makes sense.
You kind of feel like you'd be more in the conversation in a way.
I don't know either way.
Yeah.
Youtube,
that's the,
that's the point there.
If he,
if you want to watch this podcast or just the excerpts and you don't want to
watch the whole podcast,
there's little excerpts.
He little lessons that I kind of separate from the podcast,
put them on.
They're shareable little nuggets.
Also we have a store Jocko,
store.com if you like shirts and whatnot.
New Designs.
I Dunno,
a week,
next week we'll have them I think new designs.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I kind of listened to the crowd a little bit.
You know,
people throw out suggestions all the time,
which,
you know,
listened to for sure.
And um,
kind of the,
the ones that,
what do you hate the word percolate to the guy?
I mean,
I'd like the word percolate better than resonate.
The ones that resonate with my soul.
You know,
that feeling.
That's the feeling I get when I say it.
When other people say it.
It sounds cool.
I just say the ones that are good.
Yeah,
that makes more sense for sure.
All right.
Yeah.
The ones that we thought are good,
we're starting to develop more and more designs and I'm have,
so yeah.
[inaudible] dot com and you know,
women's stuff is on there.
Some patches,
some shirts of course,
brash guard.
See,
this is what,
this is the thing.
See,
I'm not good at recognizing like,
hey,
we should make more stuff.
Right.
Because I,
it's hard for me to recognize what's good and what's bad because my mind is
different than some peoples.
Yeah.
So,
but what's cool is when I do see something and I do think it's good,
it's pretty good.
Yeah.
Pretty good.
By the way.
I'm almost done with the Echo Charles tee shirt design by the way.
Yeah.
Which I think people are going to like,
you know,
why they're going to like it because you designed it well.
Yeah.
But,
but that's not why they're going to like it because it's not just
straightforward,
right?
There's yes.
Some layers is there.
And how that one,
no,
I believe bright.
You're the,
you're the original layer creator really when it comes down to it,
no,
I think that is cause flooding.
So speaking of layers,
the day that echo asked me what font it was that I used to write Jocko podcast
and I was like,
yeah,
it's the OCR standards in.
Then he kind of looked at me and I said,
it's because it's a machine can read it and you know,
this is like part machine here.
And he was all excited and laters right.
They're
telling you the laser real
and I respect them.
Good.
So yeah,
there it is.
Jocko store.
I'm also,
Oh yeah,
let's,
sorry Brett.
This rash guards on their alleged 19% straight up,
19% increase improvement performance,
um,
result,
all that stuff.
Hoodies on there too.
And you know,
like I said,
it's more stuff that we have a travel mug coming out.
That one's going to be good.
So I'll let you know when that's not a psycho psychological warfare.
I feel like I should talk about that right now.
I feel like we can't stop you.
So yeah,
I guess you can't stop me.
So psychological warfare on iTunes is an album with tracks
and this is what it's for.
It's not music.
No,
this is what it's for.
It's technically,
it's considered spoken word is what it is.
If you're feeling a moment of weakness in your discourse,
did I use that word rate discourse is not really.
Yeah.
So in your course,
I don't know,
better closer in your journey,
in your ambitious goals to stay on the program in whatever capacity.
Wake up early,
get the workout in and hardware cut in.
Um,
you know,
create,
write your book,
your blog,
your anything you're doing right,
more or less,
and you're feeling moments,
a weakness.
You're slipping from the path.
You're taking a break when you shouldn't be taking a break.
Scheduling unscheduled rest days.
Yeah.
When you're feeling like that string from the warpath.
You listened to one of these designated tracks and it'll help you get past that
weakness.
In that moment,
I would say,
and I've said this before,
it is,
this is my guess 100% chance that it will get you through your weakness.
100% chance.
And this is why I say that,
and I've said this before,
but I think it's worth saying again,
because if you,
let's say,
you know,
let's do the,
the awake though,
the workout one,
that's the most common went to me.
And I'm like,
okay,
I'm gonna work.
I don't feel like working out.
And I'm like,
okay,
well I'm going to put it in workout and track whatever the one I listened to it
and after I'm done listening to,
it's like two minutes long and I still skip the workout.
That's like a shame.
That's an unbearable shame.
And it's all personal.
So that means it's not 100% of you still skip the workout.
I'm just trying to imagine if that were to happen.
I've never done it.
And the shame,
the unbearable shame is so unbearable that it just simply wouldn't happen.
You know?
So that that's why I say 100% chance.
I don't think,
I can't imagine a person that would actually let that happen nonetheless.
So whatever your would think your weakness is waking up early,
all this stuff.
If you do the wake up early one and you set it as your alarm,
which is a good idea by the way,
it's actually,
that's the perfect idea to just clear it with your,
your spouse,
significant other significant other.
Yeah.
If they're sleeping in the same bed or whatever and they have the potential to
hear it.
There's some dude in the bedroom.
Yeah.
Just like all of a sudden starts talking and his Jocko,
it's like a spot,
you know,
it's good psychological warfare,
iTunes,
Jocko Willink gets a also on Amazon music and all these other things.
So yeah,
it's there.
It's a good way to support and support yourself because it balances support
yourself situation for sure.
Sure.
Um,
and actually what's going out right now?
We're getting requests for psychological warfare to what topics need to be
covered that I didn't cover on the first one.
Yeah.
There's more weaknesses out there in the world.
Weaknesses that are creeping around and you're trying to get people.
But yeah,
we're going to drinking and go find some of them weaknesses and we're going to
smash him.
So yeah,
if you've got any more suggestions,
just hit it up,
you know,
quitting smoking.
How about that one?
Right.
That's a good one.
Do people still smoke bro?
I that you know what I brought was thinking about that.
We live in California,
that's one of the things we live in California in California,
but a lot of people don't smoke anymore.
He's not real popular out here anymore.
Yeah.
So just like I'm pro,
I'm telling we live in a bubble,
not only being in California,
but just think about the people you hang around with.
You know,
it's like all navy seals,
Gj guys who at the very least have like some level of health conscious.
Yes,
exactly.
So yeah,
it's weird.
I thought guys smoking in his car and I was like,
I ask the same thing.
I was like,
Dang,
I didn't know really people smoked anymore.
Really.
I realized that when I go to another state,
yes.
And you go into a restaurant or something cause it's legal here.
You can't smoke in a restaurant.
You can't smoke in a bar here.
You can't do it.
It's illegal.
It's literally illegal.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you go to another state and you and you smell cigarettes and go,
oh yeah,
I remember that back.
But yeah,
that'd be a good one I think.
Okay,
well we'll,
we'll think about that one.
Craving.
I don't know if I could legally do it though,
because I didn't smoke and I don't know what it takes.
I don't know if it's proper for me to do that.
I mean,
I guess I could just get nuts off smoke.
Yeah.
Cause I mean it's a horrible thing that kills you.
You shouldn't be doing it,
man.
I,
there's actually no benefit from it.
Right.
There's no,
I mean if you're doing steroids,
there's some benefit to it,
right.
You're going to get stronger.
If you're doing caffeine,
you're going to be more awake.
So there's certain benefits.
Is there any benefits to smoking?
It depends on what you mean by,
do you ever smoke before?
I've never even tried a puff of a cigarette before because you're from Hawaii.
Well that's not the reason people smoke.
It was the thing,
his thing with my dad,
he,
he'd literally refer to it as the devil.
Like he'd be like,
fuck,
it's the devil.
And it was,
it was a shame thing too.
So the way he would talk about Spokane,
not necessarily the people that smoke,
but smoking.
Yeah.
It's just so it just to me,
in my mind,
according to his little,
that's cool.
Mess.
So your dad has done a good job there and I had never checked anyway.
He should have told you sleep was the devil to get you out of the bed,
not the devil.
That's the thing.
I know.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
I think it's,
um,
there is benefits though.
Depends on when you're smoking.
It depends on what you mean by benefits.
The health benefits of any
guide.
It gives you like this,
this like buzz and alerting.
But here's the thing about her,
it's weird because if you say smoking,
smoking cigarettes,
there's nicotine in it and there's benefits in nicotine.
But smoking also has all the carbon monoxide,
like tar,
all these carcinogens and stuff like that.
Yeah.
So smoking
maybe not so much benefits.
Nicotine.
There are benefits.
Okay,
well let's just say no.
Just say no.
There are no better.
So that's net benefit.
No native.
Alright.
And um,
let's see.
Also speaking of net benefit,
you can get some net benefit if you want to try something called Jocko white
tea.
If you're worried,
if you're not a tea drinker,
don't worry cause it doesn't taste like tea.
Tastes like victory.
And you know,
don't take my word for it.
I got some reviews,
we got some,
we've got a bunch of reviews on Amazon and you know what?
They're all awesome.
They're all 12 star,
right?
So here's one.
After drinking one cup of this balanced and delicious tea,
I was able to execute a flying triangle on my black belt Jujitsu instructor
while discovering the mystery behind dark matter in the universe.
It actually isn't dark martyr.
It's a combination of Jockos Chan,
Echo Charles,
his biceps,
altering the gravitational field from random celestial bodies.
So you know,
there's some good stuff here.
I can't speak to dead lift performance,
but what I can comment as a significant increase in production while performing
farm work.
Most noticeably,
I can dig postholes in hard southern clay and half the normal time while under
the influence of Jocko white tea tastes great and I highly recommend it for
farmers,
landscapers,
construction warders workers or anyone who wants to get after it.
So I didn't,
you know,
I wasn't familiar with that.
But you do notice right now like the economy's improving a lot.
We'll look,
you know,
everything's getting better.
I think it's got a lot of people aren't drinking chocolate either.
Working harder so that you're seeing quarterly.
You're not necessarily saying,
I'm not saying it's a fact,
I'm just saying it's factual.
And you know this guy here bought this from my wife,
she's five,
220 pounds.
She was dead lifting 250 pounds by the way.
That's double body weight already impressive.
After a week of imbibing this fine product,
her dead lift suddenly increase to 1,250 pounds.
Now that might seem like a lot,
but it's,
it happens,
right?
It's right there.
I mean this has been documented on Amazon.
Reviews can't lie on those.
We started throwing Jocko white tea bags in 500 gallon water tank on the
firetruck.
Little known fact Jocko white teeth,
three times a wetter.
You're now extinguishing fires three times faster.
And in the process,
anyone on scene who gets sprayed immediately getting after it.
So there's a little side effect,
but it's a positive side effect or a negative that you're putting out the fire.
Someone say he gets hit with some water by accident,
they're not going to complain.
Then you started doing burpees.
Uh,
we got a warning here too aggressive,
do not drink at work.
Literally lip the ripped the door trim off the wall after consuming this victory
in a glass.
Luckily since getting after it is my new default mode,
I was able to repair the damage before the boss noticed.
Replaced pathetic.
This is my best part or the best part of this one.
Replaced pathetic screws with lag bolts.
You know what lag bolts are there like instead of a screw,
which is like a little tiny pencil thing.
A lag bolt is a big bolt that you like.
Yeah,
that's your mind salt.
Now I mentioned this before and I don't know if I should necessarily do this,
but I kind of think I should.
Got It.
There's a poem that someone wrote about Jocko white tea and it's based on the
poem infantry columns by Kipling.
This one is talking about Jocko white tea.
Probably worth talking about here.
Yes,
so we'll go.
Here we go.
Jocko white tea.
I'm hot.
Bru Bru Bru Bru brewing up some Jocko tea.
Hot,
hot,
brewing up some Jocko tea,
drink,
drink it down and brew again.
There is no tea leaves in the poor.
Three to four five Tasty Cup of Dia de seven three five nine cups the day
before.
Drink,
drink,
drink it down and brew again.
There's no tea leaves in the poor du Du du Du crush.
What is in front of you.
Drink,
drink,
drink it down and brew again.
Good,
good,
good.
We'll answer everything.
There's no tea leaves in the poor.
I've drank whole box and getting after it,
press the lift squat role then right back to it again.
Drink,
drink,
drink it down on Bro.
Again,
hadn't,
there's no tea leaves in the pore.
So just when someone writes a review like that,
I think that might be the best.
And matter of fact,
let's just face it.
That's the best review.
That's everything on Amazon.
So good on you.
That's the best review.
It was very impressive.
It's very impressive.
And uh,
so that's that also if you want to preorder,
um,
a little book coming out called the way the war,
your kid and you can order it and I'll tell you why this book,
you might be wondering what this book is about.
This book is about everything.
So I want to read a little excerpt to you
young mark.
Remember the beginning of the book,
he could do zero pullups doesn't know how to do any pull ups,
wasn't strong enough.
Now he works through the summer.
His uncle Jake is shown him some good workout programs and finally he's built up
over the summer.
It goes through some plateaus,
gets through them getting after it,
training hard.
Finally towards the end of summer he gets his first day of doing 10 pull ups.
Right,
and so here's what happens.
We're going back to the book and that was it.
I was now officially a kid who can do 10 pull ups.
No more hiding from the pullup bar in school.
No more being embarrassed about being weak.
This was real.
As I thought about this,
I looked at uncle Jake and said,
thanks.
No problem,
mark,
and I want you to remember something.
This isn't just about pull ups.
You know what else this is about,
right?
I wasn't quite sure.
I don't know.
Uncle Jake grabbed me by both shoulders and looked me straight in the eyes and
said,
gravely,
this is about everything.
Everything.
Just think two months ago you couldn't do any pull ups at all.
Zero.
Now you can do 10 all it took was a good plan and the discipline to execute that
plan to do it,
that's what it takes.
And you can apply that to just about anything.
If you are willing to do the work,
you can make things happen.
And like I told you,
no one else is going to do the work for you.
Sure you might get some help along the way,
but you might not.
Who knows what we do know is this hard work and discipline are how you achieve
things.
You have to make things happen and that is exactly what you did here.
And you can do that with almost anything in life.
Remember that
Uncle Jake's putting out some words,
the young mark.
So there's all kinds of good lessons for,
you know,
I'd love to say it's a kids book.
It's a kid's book basically.
I'm going to tell you what you might want to order it for yourself.
It's everybody.
It's everybody book that just,
it's an everybody book.
So that's that.
Check out.
That book also just released discipline equals freedom field manual.
Sometimes we need to refer to the manual on how to do things right.
We need the manual if we're going to refer to it.
It's true.
Manuals coming.
You can preorder that one too.
It's about everything.
You know that one's more aimed at an adult audience.
Yeah,
it is adult.
Yeah.
Dig.
Not that there's like bad words in it or anything like that.
There's no obscene topics unless you think donuts are a bad word because they're
in there.
We talk about them a little bit and their,
their evilness.
So yeah,
you can,
you can get that one too.
Of course you can get extreme ownership.
It's about leadership in combat.
In business,
it's about life and you know from what we learned in combat,
the lessons that we learned in combat,
they will help you in your business and they will help you in life.
So get a copy,
get a copy for your team and you know,
get up and down the chain of command up and down the chain of command.
They need it.
Also,
I wanted to mention this echelon front,
right?
This is the company Leif Babin and I who wrote the book extreme ownership with
me.
This is our company leadership and management consulting.
It's what we do.
We've also got JP Danelle onboard.
We got Dave Burke on board and we work with companies,
help them align their leadership around the principles from the book extreme
ownership of the things we learned in combat.
If you need this,
and this is the reason I'm saying this right now,
normally I don't talk about or I haven't talked about as much,
but people sometimes have a hard time figuring out how to get information on
front.com.
That's the business website.
If you want to bring us onboard info@echelonfront.com,
you can email at that address and then people can uh,
get there.
You don't need to go to a speaker's bureau if you want to hear me speak or if
you want to hear Lafe speaker,
if you want to hear cause a speakers bureau is,
um,
they are there companies that,
that facilitates speakers coming.
They're like an agent.
So if you don't know how to contact,
if you want to hear Jocko talk,
you want to have jack who come and talk at your company,
you type speaker,
Jocko Willink,
there's a good chance echelon front will come up and say,
Oh yeah,
you can call this number or you can email here and that'll hook it up.
Or there'll be someone else that says,
you know,
Bill's speakers and they're advertising me,
their advertising everybody people.
And they said,
hey,
if you want it,
then they contact us.
But you got them.
You got yourself a middleman in that scenario.
So yeah.
Actually that's good because like people still email me.
Yeah.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
would you echo,
can you come and talk at our company?
No,
no.
Did you tell her?
Can you tell us about on it?
Yeah,
no,
I think yours,
you forward those those things to me too.
And I didn't know the inflight,
I'll send them to like Jamie or something.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's uh,
that's,
but yeah,
so that's what you do.
Yes.
Infomercial on front.com and you know,
between me,
between life,
JP,
Dave Burke,
and we do,
we do programs like full programs at your company to get everybody aligned and
on the same page.
So that's what we do.
If you want to get some of that.
And also you can come to the muster in New York City,
New York City,
right.
Can't be mad at New York City.
That's the place we're going to be.
May 4th or May 5th doing at the Marriott Grand Marquis.
Now a couple things about the muster,
okay.
This is,
this is different.
Okay?
This isn't a feel good seminar to like pump you up.
That is not what's happening at the muster if you want that don't come.
Yeah.
I'm not saying you won't be pumped up.
I'm not saying you won't be motivated,
but don't come if that's what you're looking for.
There's not going to be any chanting.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's not going to be any like communal promises and that kind of stuff.
That's,
and that's not happening there.
You're not going to fill out,
um,
a dream board.
Okay.
That's not happening.
Don't come to the muster if that's what you want.
That's not what the muster is.
This is practical tactics,
tactics and strategies,
practical things that will help you lead your team and we'll help you lead
yourself.
So if that's what you want,
then come to the muster.
If you want to chance and promise and stuff like this don't come because that's
not what it is.
If you want to learn how to lead,
come.
Yeah,
yeah,
there,
I mean I'm just obviously going on the last one,
but like you learn like scenarios,
you know that the Q and a part is straight up golden because everyone comes
like,
Hey,
I had this scenario that's been basically plaguing me for a year and it's just
causing problems here and you know,
and everyone has their own one and while they're all unique,
they all kind of overlap with each other and,
and you guys were like,
okay,
this is what you do.
This will you do,
this is the answering.
It's like,
Dang,
we now we have an answer.
We go back to the work in it.
Like a lot of times it will just solve this one problem that affects all this
other stuff,
man.
It's,
it's so funny.
It is.
And when people come and they hear those questions get asked,
and,
and again,
they're all,
there's always an overlap on the questions,
right?
And,
and there's overlap on the principals as well,
you know,
covering,
move,
simple,
prioritize.
Next Xq decentralized command.
Those,
the explanations can stand alone on themselves,
but you start getting into real world application,
there's going to be other there.
They're gonna overlap you.
You need all four of them,
right?
You need all four of them to solve your problem.
You can't just solve a problem with decentralized command because if you try and
do that,
you'll make something too complex.
You've got to keep it simple.
And by the way,
there's gonna be multiple problems that you're gonna be trying to solve with
your decentralized command.
So you've got to prioritize and execute.
So that's the way it is for every,
every problem that you're,
you're suffering.
And then there's,
you know,
there's obviously other other principles that we build upon that aren't just the
four laws of combat.
So you gotta get you gotta.
That's what's good is when people hear the way that you utilize these tools,
they learned to utilize them themselves,
right?
That's,
that's what you're trying to do.
It's like trying to teach someone to take pictures,
right?
You don't just you,
and I'm saying this because you know I had been talking about cameras.
You don't just say,
okay,
here point this point.
Set the setting to this.
Set the light over here.
Set this up,
press this button and there's your picture.
That's cool.
It works.
Now one time,
what happens when I step outside and there's different lighting and what happens
when the subject is moving?
You got to teach me how to do the job.
You got to teach me the intricates,
Chrissy's intricacies of it.
You've got to show me all those things.
I got to learn how to use that tool and that's what we do at the monster.
You get these various tools.
You don't just read about them and see what they are.
And say,
okay,
I understand what this tool is here.
I'm holding this tool in my hand,
it's sharp.
I can cut with it.
Well guess what else are you can do with this?
There's a lot of things you can do with these tools that we put out at the
muster.
We take it to the next level.
So if that's what you're looking for,
calm to the monster,
common,
the monster,
and we got great feedback across the board.
So yeah,
come and get that.
In the meantime also,
if there's something that you want to ask or you have a question or you want to
give some feedback or comment about what we're doing here,
or if you knew,
if you just want to cruise with Hito with Echo Charles primarily,
he's kind of the primary cruiser here.
Yes.
Uh,
we're on the interwebs right now,
today,
yesterday.
We'll be there tomorrow.
Twitter,
Instagram.
And you know that we also,
we gotta be on that Facebook [inaudible] and you can get us there.
Echo is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and to close this out for the day,
thanks.
First of all,
to all the people in uniform that are out there holding the line against terror,
against extremism,
against criminals,
against fire and disaster against accidents and against the unexpected.
All of you.
Thank you for keeping us safe and everyone else out there.
Thank you for listening.
And I would also ask that you be thankful.
You be thankful for your freedom,
okay?
Your precious and costly freedom.
Because sometimes when something is given to us,
just given to us,
okay,
we forget what the cost was.
We'd forget the price that was paid,
okay?
Then there was a path,
a price paid for our freedom,
a massive price.
Yeah,
there are those that paid everything they had for our freedom.
So don't waste it.
Don't abuse it,
don't squander it.
Our time
is limited.
Your time here is limited
and you have this freedom.
You have this gift.
So what are you going to do with it?
What are you going to do with it today?
Right now?
Ask yourself that question.
Ask
and then go out
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.